Oh, that's right.
No, no animation.
No waiting animation.
We out.
We out here.
All right.
The hoes are watching.
Yeah.
Altair, what was that catchphrase that you wanted to say after that?
Suck it, nerds.
Oh, no.
He did not say that.
It was not nerds.
It was sucking something, but it wasn't nerds.
Suck it, noobs.
The hoes are watching.
All right.
Come on, Altair.
You know you want to say it.
It starts with a P. Pokemon.
Dang, of course he's into that.
You guys are trying to get me.
You guys are trying to get all my videos restricted, huh?
No, no, of course not.
Oh, no, we would never do that to you.
Because if your videos get restricted, our videos get restricted too, because we're streaming with you.
Hey, mine gets restricted anyways.
It don't really matter.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I got my Garfield video restricted because I sang a very inappropriate song.
I sang a very inappropriate song as Garfield.
Garfield's thing's inappropriate songs?
Yeah, it was, yeah.
I thought inappropriate songs only existed like Rick and Morty and South Park and shit for you.
Like, you know, I said I was rapping a very inappropriate song.
What was it about?
Give us a context.
Why was it so inappropriate?
It was like, you know, Lonely Island.
You know, Lonely Island.
No, I just touched.
oh and it felt so good that was so good yeah so it was from the lonely item it was very inappropriate and i did it as garfield i mean come on that's a classic though no no it wasn't that it was a lot worse it was a lot worse oh okay so you didn't go with the classic you went with like an og yeah yeah yeah an og son from snl hey guys hello everybody welcome to battlefield Redseg.
So the only person with the most experience is Axel.
He's also going to be the one with the most pain.
No, no, no, no.
I am not experienced at all.
The one with the most experience and it's going to carry both Altair and I will be Axel.
Axel, I expect high things from you, buddy.
Yeah, I expect so much from you, Axel.
Nah, I'm going to be browsing Twitter, dude.
You all do you love me.
You were the one that you like.
I love battlefield.
I love Redseg.
Whoa, I never said that.
Come on, man.
I didn't say that.
I was so excited to play Red Sacky.
That's what you said.
No, I said I didn't sleep because I had shit going on.
No, no.
You were like, I love Red Sack.
And you were like, yesterday I was playing Red Sack.
Yeah, yeah, you're like, I was playing Red Sack yesterday too.
And we're like, whoa, really?
Yeah, I was playing a bit.
I was playing a bit.
But that doesn't mean I'm good, you know.
But hey, at least my PC runs smoothly this time.
You know, that's one good thing.
Yeah, that's good.
It always had me, yo.
you as the group leader so invite us yeah okay i'll give me one second i have i have someone narrating the menus for me oh oh wait you haven't even put up the game that means it's the first time putting up the game i thought you said you played a little bit you guys give me one second all right one it was a dream i don't know what role is the best oh yeah we're talking about oh Axel wants to be a doctor so he could use a defib on people.
Or a pyromaniac.
Or a pyro.
That's not a doctor.
That's not...
That's a big deal.
Close enough.
So, one fucking...
One saves lives.
The other take lives.
I mean, technically, the doctor can do both if you want to, but...
Nah, nah, it's designed to take your life.
You know why?
So they can keep...
They keep stealing your money.
You know they all have that cure in their basement.
so you can make more money off of them you just don't cure them fully so you cure them 90 yeah if you cure them 90 broken no they'll like keep coming back if you kill every time yeah yeah every time i just fly back to osiland or fly over to japan i always just pray i just hope that there is no cancer research doctor on my plane you know what i'm saying i'm i'm always like them I'm just like,
I pray the Lord.
Please, no researchers on my plane.
Wait, why?
Why not on your plane?
I mean, you're still here.
Hey, they don't get me if I talk too much.
Oh, yeah, yeah, they got him.
See, the hoses are watching.
Like I said in the beginning.
The hoses are watching, bro.
All right, party.
Axel, as a doctor.
Join party.
Have you taken the Hippocratic Oath, or are you just a hypocrite?
I don't think he's like...
What the hell is that?
I don't think he's a server.
definitely has not taken the Hippocratic Oath.
Oh no.
I don't know what a Hippocrate is.
He really is a doctor that can kill.
He is a doctor that can kill.
So a Hippocratic Oath is something that every doctor takes to make that basically means you don't kill.
That's like the whole premise.
Nah, fuck that shit, dude.
Like that's the Oath.
You make an Oath that you would never kill.
I ain't making an Oath.
I guess intentionally.
It's something I can't promise, you know?
That's true.
What if I walk in the room and then they decided blow himself up?
You know, like, that's not really on me.
That's not your fault.
But it's going to look like I did it, dude.
I walk down.
How would it look like you did it?
You carry a bomb around you all the time as a doctor?
Yeah, you never know when the next Hex of Solomonka is going to appear in a fucking room, you know.
Why would you carry a bomb around you?
Just carry a gun.
It's a Hex of Solomonka.
Well, I mean, a bomb can come in handy.
Ooh, talking about a bomb.
They, uh, they thought I, they thought I was, uh, they thought I was a bomber.
what i went to the airport because my my asmr mike he was in like a case i thought you brought your asmr but we haven't done asmr wait you've done yeah and and and and i got like flick switches and shit on it right they thought i had like a bomb in there and i was like ah and it was like an old gaza as well it was like handling that shit so he didn't know what the fuck asmr was it was it one of the breakdown everything yeah yeah crazy expensive one yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not gonna be a jump leader is your also i hope there's no spmm on this because like i don't remember i don't remember how to play this game what the hell is it yeah you know rspca whatever the hell that is rspca what isn't that like the free the free range chicken shit you know what what do you mean what is that yeah i fuck with kfc you know me and kfc we go way back okay i i don't know i i think he's very tired i wait what that's just how i feel spring marks you know he just kind of i don't know what he's talking
about anymore wait what gun is why the hell is my god all right i have have stun grenades i'm testing my gun out oh that's me testing my gun out it's a respawn pot tower gotcha sound yeah i lowered altair a little bit let me know if it's good okay now it's doing well what's this oh i'm chilling i'm just trying to fix my like sensitivity sniper rifle wait what do you select mission for ducky you're pretty good at sniping do you want the rifle i don't even don't i don't even know what gun is good here you're the sniper you've
you've always been the sniper oh hey knife airstrike all right so now we're just looting looting oh my god guys actually i forgot i had my push the mute give me a sec i i don't know you guys figure it out yourself you guys are adults as well okay you gotta stop relying on if you don't teach us we'll lower your kda oh i don't give a shit about kda you know i'm not like one of those filthy kda players okay then we'll we'll bring you What do you mean you are a filthy KDA player?
You just run away.
You can call it.
I don't even know if my guns are...
Oh, you got a key card.
You can get attacked with that.
Did you know that?
Yeah, I got a key card.
Well, are we playing with bots?
I don't know.
How do I use my key card?
So you gotta go to that right.
You see what...
Is it a vehicle trailer?
Yeah, yeah, that one, that one.
We gotta go there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice box.
I know.
I hope we're against bots because like we need we need help.
We need help.
Yeah, we need something.
Can you buy the defib in this in this?
I think you gotta be a doctor to use the defib, don't you?
Like other than 10 years of education.
You become good friends with people in the government, you know?
Oh, that's true, true.
I can just, like, you know, use political power to become a doctor.
Yes, sir.
We can get a tank for this.
Oh, I have a vehicle card.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's great.
How do I do it?
Confirm.
The tanks are broken.
I don't know.
Do I go over here and just use my slide my card?
I think over here.
All right.
I'll go for it.
Granted.
I got it.
Now we just got to wait.
It's a loot box, Axel.
The loot box.
Yay.
Yes, sir.
Oh, my God.
Come on, give me a Lamborghini.
Lamborghini.
Come on, gold, gold, gold.
I just want a tank.
Gold, gold, gold.
I don't even want a Lamborghini.
I want a cyber truck.
It looks so fucking ugly.
I just want good hard pot, man.
All right, hop on in, bitches.
It's a tank.
All right.
Oh, I got the cannon.
Do I get anything?
Don't chill in.
All right, if you...
Oh, I'll tear.
I'll tear.
You're literally the driver.
Why did you get out of the car?
I thought trapped in there with you.
Targeted.
Wait, what?
Who's targeting us?
I don't know.
How do people even target us?
It's a tank in the arena, I think.
Okay, we just got to find people and kill them, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
Can we run the whole river with a tank?
I think so.
Oh, okay.
We just should.
Beep, beep.
Beep, beep, beep.
Signal rate.
Oh, so there's a mission that someone picked where they try to kill us.
Oh Someone picked a mission to destroy our tank What we did to do that we worked hard for this tank.
It's our family tank.
Oh, wait is it that?
Is it that red shit over there Oh shit.
What the fuck?
I can't move.
Oh my god.
Its findings.
Spiders.
I see him.
It's the finest his finest.
Oh my god.
I'm leaving.
Oh, artillery, battalion.
I know.
I don't think they're bots they're not they're bots.
They were absolutely not bots.
17, purple.
They're coming up, coming up, coming up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
One dead, one dead.
I sent one in as well.
Wait, wake up.
I'm taking this guy down.
I accidentally hit that guy with that.
He was behind me this entire time?
Yeah, I was fucking him.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Okay, I need to get armor.
Give me a sec.
I'm...
Armoring, armoring real quick.
He's running away.
all right all right i didn't realize he was right behind us what does he have i have a grenade yeah it's a assault rifle oh i want to upgrade yoink oh my god i think you're gone i think they ran what the hell they're getting killed they're getting killed really they are how do you know now that's my other side okay okay yeah let's push up let's go oh wait wait i got a kill You got him!
You got him!
I told Mr. Felice, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
These guys are definitely not bots, though, for real.
Oh, wait, wait.
He's right here.
Right here.
Right behind that truck.
Oh, never mind.
No, no, no.
He's still alive.
You haven't killed him.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's right there.
He's right there.
Oh, my God.
I didn't see him.
He's right there.
Oh, God.
He's looking at me.
I got one.
I need a bait.
Nice.
On my way, Doki!
I need some help!
I need help!
He's fine!
He doesn't need help!
He's full HP.
I got him!
I killed him!
Oh my goodness!
Wait, there's a guy in front of us!
He's right here!
Yeah, I don't really have cover.
I'm gonna back up a little.
Oh my god, wait.
You can rest me behind this wall.
This wall is safe.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got sniped.
Okay, take it, take it.
Okay, I'm ready.
Appreciate it, appreciate it.
Here you go, you're so safe.
You're still healthy.
I think, oh, oh my god.
I got, I got, I got police deal again.
There's an artillery.
I'm backing up.
Oh, we got squad weight.
We got squad.
Yeah, we got squad weight.
We got a squad weight.
I'm grabbing armor.
One of my favorite points is over the edge.
Oh, my God.
I got half of these freaking strikes!
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I think we're fine.
We're fine.
We're still healthy.
I didn't get a chance to lose.
Is there a tank?
Aish.
Oh my god.
My back was wide open.
We are so healthy.
Oh, we are not healthy!
We are not healthy!
That's a tank, that's a tank, that's a tank.
That's a tank, that's a tank.
Ooh, is a tank?
Who's a tank?
Look at him in the middle!
like what how the hell did i okay i'm safe i'm safe i'm safe dude why are they not destroying their tank but when it's our tank everyone wants to get a piece of it you know um guys they are right there that is hard to use wow wait oh he sees me he saw me he saw me oh we got redeployed nice they're cheaters gave pity on us oh thank god second chance i was i was telling too much you know they were like yeah that's not fair how come like when we have a tank they all took a shot at us but when they have a tank no one cared oh it's been looted has this been looted get to that rv point move i'm checking oh someone just landed what's that that's me that's not me that's not me i i was lying Oh,
wait, that's a bike.
A bicycle.
There is a...
Right here.
I don't know.
You saw me.
You might have saw me.
Yeah, you far as fuck.
Oh, guys, guys.
Guys.
There is a...
Hello, hello, hello.
Good luck and see you in the next life.
Yes, okay.
Remember me.
No, Axel, no.
Remember me, please.
He
was so low.
Okay, it's okay.
Axel is alive.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
What the hell are they?
Oh.
That's too difficult, man.
That's too difficult.
To be fair, we're all split up.
Okay.
How many teams are there?
How many teams in total?
I think there's like 70, 80, 90.
Couple.
Yep.
I just, you know, we were learning.
Elter and I were learning.
So, you know, like, I think we did pretty good for people who never know how to play the game yet, you know.
I'm level 2.
Yeah, wait, am I level 2?
Yeah, I'm level 2 too.
Wait, I think?
Why do you always have to steal my thunder?
Wait, no, you're level 1.
What do you mean?
I'm level 2.
No, you're not.
I can see it.
You can't gaslight me like this.
No, I won't let it happen.
I love it.
I can't literally see that you're level 1.
on my screen like yeah no i think your thigh was mine mine's level two oh hey i'm level two yay guys get a grind level jesus you're already level 13 extra yes sir i got kicked from the lobby what you did you're still party leader i'm stupid never mind yeah i was gonna say it says you're party leader why did it kick us from the squad uh from the quads then i guess like The game felt bad for us.
It was like, you're not ready.
Apparently there's 25 squads, so we did okay.
Yeah, we did pretty well.
We're not last.
That's all that matters.
You're not the worst.
I just wish Axel would carry a little bit more.
Yeah, I know, right?
Yeah, look at the score.
You know.
Look at that.
Altair got three kills.
I was harassing them.
Well, physically damage and mental damage.
Mental damage is sometimes more important.
to one another you know you were you were doing the artillery strike mm-hmm exactly i have my ways of going oh wait support wait defib i have defib i have defib gotta do yeah yeah yeah oh my god and we have oh my god he's going to carry us he's on fire a bastion he's a controller andy as well he has amuses just gonna he does he's a cheater yeah yeah yeah we like that we like cheaters
But like, we don't endorse it.
We stand for jiggers in this house.
But like, but like, that's a joke, guys.
We don't endorse hacking in video games.
Only these raw skills.
Wait, I don't get a defense?
Then what the fuck am I being support for?
Meant a moral support?
Oh, fuck that.
It's okay, I'm moral support too.
Oh, wait, we're working for NATO.
Bye.
tornado yeah we're working for nato we're here to we're here for that was a nato you don't national american terrorist organization that's not what nato stands for it is not just and tacos only okay all right here we go i'm breaking off i'm going solo Oh shit,
we got company.
We got company.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Is there friendly fire in this game?
We got holes on us.
Uh, I don't.
There is.
All right.
Is there or is there not?
Okay, no.
Okay.
I was gonna test it out with someone.
There isn't.
All right.
Who'd you shoot?
You shot me.
No, I didn't.
You don't have proof.
So you didn't take damage.
Wow.
I can't believe you were shooting me like that.
You have no proof.
You took no damage.
Can't believe it.
I looked.
I saw it in the above.
Alright, let's see.
I was shooting the sidearm around.
Oh, that's not you!
That's not you!
Okay.
Oh, you see me?
I fell from the sky like Spider-Man.
Oh, my God.
My hero.
Okay, you got...
Yeah, maybe.
Where, where?
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
Oh, he's dead.
I thought it was you shooting me again, but this time I took damage.
Also, there's a guy right here.
All part of my plan.
Oh, I see you.
Where's the slide?
How do you slide in this game?
Double tap C.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Okay, hero assassin has a tank.
I don't know how.
Oh, army, army, army.
Inside, inside, inside.
He dumped him, locked him.
Yeah, we got both.
We got both.
That's right.
Oh.
Tag!
I got healer.
Alright.
Oh, they had good guns.
Yeah, they do.
Thank you.
Thank you for your guns.
Thank you for kind donation.
I wonder where's the last guy?
That wasn't a squad right, though.
Homeboy died.
Oh shit, assassin.
Wait, how did he die?
Oh, here!
I see him.
He's peeking through the...
Oh, that's how he died!
That's how he died!
He has a missile.
He's right here.
Well you know what?
That's when you go close range.
Yeah!
I believe in you.
I'll watch from far far here.
Oh there he is!
He is over here.
He's over here.
Behind this.
Oh my god.
Behind that, behind you.
Nice.
That's right.
...say hi to my grandma in the grave.
Damn.
Where the fuck is our guy?
Maybe inside?
Oh he says the bazooka.
Yeah you dead dad.
Don't worry he'll redeploy.
No, no, he's still alive.
Mr. High Assassin.
Yeah, he's coming back.
He got kicked out of hell.
Whoa!
What?
Our welding just exploded behind us.
Oh, no.
Wait, someone's got to be in there.
What do I have?
People, people, people, people.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, ping, ping, ping, ping.
Okay.
I got a scout.
I'll take high ground.
I don't know where high ground is.
I'm going to...
There's somewhere on the left side, I think.
I can't...
I don't think I can take high ground.
Oh, he was on the left.
All right.
Oh, no.
That's not supposed to be just out there that I was just shooting.
One more, one more, one more, one more.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I see him.
They parachuted.
So, they parachuted.
Good another day.
I don't see anyone.
Can you guys ping?
Dude, Dad?
Ah, he's back.
Hmm.
We're somewhere over here.
Yeah, I saw like, oh, I see him.
I see him.
Fandom.
Ooh, this gun sucks.
He's right here.
He's right here on the roof.
He heard me.
I shot my gun.
He's still behind this.
He's just behind this area.
Called Killed on, killed on.
Oh, he's not pushing up.
He's not peeking.
He's not peeking me.
He's still behind here.
Wait, this is a different guy?
I thought- Parachute towards us.
What the heck?
That's a different guy we're fighting.
Yeah, I'm looking at him.
Looking at a different guy.
I mean, you guys.
Oh, we all looking at different dudes.
Oh, wait.
There's two teams.
He's shooting at a different team.
Well, it is what it is.
That's what that's what the war field is gonna be like, you know, are you okay over there because I'm three thousand people out there I'm suppressed already.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you are not okay There's like a lot of people no okay.
I'm coming over.
I guess I'll help out now I broke my legs.
I'm hit you're me me me me Don't die don't die
Oh, wait, that's you.
Oh, I'm here.
Somewhere on ping?
Where?
Red ping, one.
Oh, okay, red ping.
There's someone up there as well, I feel like.
I don't see anybody.
Watch out the silos.
There's like a lot of people on the silos.
Oh, my, my, my, my, my, my.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Going up.
I'm getting armored.
I don't see him.
He ping?
He's like here.
Yeah, I don't- he's not peeking me now.
I didn't- Let's hit him!
2020 right here!
He's crashed.
I'll be shot from my side!
He was shooting me from my- Oh!
There's a guy right here that's it.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Shit!
Oh, no, I have redeployed so.
Just rush me like that.
Altair now has second chance.
Wait, can we like rise you or no after you will die?
Please.
Uh, now you gotta use the redeploy tower after that.
Oh, guess what I see?
Guess what I see?
Oh, I see it.
Oh, I wonder what that is.
All right.
Give it a few of us.
We just applied around a small little proximity, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was quick, wasn't it?
That was quick.
Yeah, see, we did it.
All right, it's fine.
We can read a play to people.
That was a quickie.
Yeah, yeah, see?
We won and done.
Now, Mr. High Assassin can come back in as well.
carry us this time yes sir i'm just out there going out getting kills and then dying getting kills and then dying that's what i do all right he should be fine now okay someone actually in this area okay i need to remember that i'm a medic and i have i oh hey guys there is some heels here oh never mind no more heels i accidentally used it
It'll use my knees.
I feel stuck in here.
How do you get out?
I'm going to grab this.
What?
I can't grab that good.
Ooh.
All right.
Where the fuck?
I'm like trapped over here.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, wasn't that...
Is there anyone here?
I'll break through this glass.
I'm going to loot in.
Oh, shit.
Okay, never.
That's scared me.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Chill, man.
There's shots West 300.
West 300.
All right, I'm heading over.
Oh, that is a...
Oh, do you need heals?
Oh, there is a lot of gunshots over there.
Oh my god.
I think they're shooting at us, guys.
Yeah, I think so too.
They might be shooting at us.
Let's just give them the axle and then we'll run.
All right, let's see.
I should need this gun.
Sacrifice.
Oh, I killed one.
How?
Oh, I killed another.
Oh, no, wait, wait.
Where were you?
Actually, you got to talk.
You got to talk.
Oh, it's a truck.
It's a truck.
There's two holes in the truck.
Oh, there's two holes.
Okay, okay.
There is a redeploy tower to my left, everyone.
Oh, I see, I see it.
Getting shot from the cross.
Oh, we're there, over there.
Ah, there's just too many on us.
It's over on my left, on my left.
Is the guy next to that redeploy tower?
Yeah, I know.
I can't do anything about it.
I was trying to get there and then...
his team ran over there i think he's trying to read the floor too it's okay take your time there's another there's another guy right here bro i don't know what to do what i would do for a chicken corn soup right now jesus can you just go to a 7-eleven they don't have chicken corn soup out of 7-eleven you know the chinese style chicken oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
you know yeah okay they're just sending it in are you serious what am i a threat to you oh they're trying to redeploy you hear that when the win he has sirens they're trying to redeploy yeah where am i getting shot from i don't know but i am inside right now that cheating bro oh wait how do you go all the way there there was a how do i see them they're wait maybe i can get redeployed you think it's possible all right i'm going with your belief i can run through this open field and not be punished surely surely i can streamer luck streamer luck that's right i'm streaming this so i should be lucky okay so like i don't know what the high assassin is doing but how did he play this is high how did he play this game for a to 53 levels and still play like this.
Oh, hey, a loot box.
Oh, hey.
Mr. High Assassin only plays like an assassin.
He's just maddened and hired.
I know, that means he's been doing this for, like, since Battle Royale was released.
All he did is just hide.
I don't think he's ever won a game in his life.
All right, here we go.
Oh, he is, Mr. High Assassin.
He only plays at this time while high.
While being an assassin.
Oh boy 1041.
Oh boy.
It'd be a shame if.
Let's hope.
Nobody comes up.
Oh shit.
No.
Oh wait.
I didn't see.
Oh my god.
He was walking.
He was.
Oh my god.
He was ratting.
He was actually rat.
Bro he did.
Oh my god.
He was baiting.
for people for res is oh my god mr high assassin don't worry i'm not interested in resing he's just looting it's like yep i'm just getting what i want maybe let's give him benefit of the doubt you know maybe he's gonna go okay it's a party or squad okay yo can you res us wait who the why is the level five the jump leader jesus this game always gives the lowest ring wait who am i talking to i think that's all right before it starts oh okay i think god i was like i was like who is travin travin nicks and shoddy the logic what shoddy the logic yeah i have shoddy the logic in my chat in my battlefield chat he's a melody in my ear well he just got shot at oh there's someone there he sees me bro what the is this guy Is he cheating?
Wait, he looks like he's cheating.
Wait, there's no way he's walling.
Wait, what?
Why did he just...
He's on a controller as well.
Wait, what?
Is he...
Oh my god!
Wait!
Wait, he sees him.
He sees him.
Wait, I think...
Wait.
Wait, wait a minute.
Guys, is he walling?
God, do you think he's...
Maybe...
Maybe he has...
Guys, do you think he's walling?
Do you think Clara and stuff?
No, no, no, no.
He ain't cheating.
He was shooting the wall though.
Okay, like, why was he looking at that wall and tracking someone?
I don't know.
It's kind of sus.
It's not gonna lie.
It's kinda.
We did better that time.
13 players.
Yeah, 13 players.
Let's go.
13.
Not bad.
I only got two kills.
I was smoking them, dude.
Yeah, I won.
Okay, but you did kill steal.
Yeah, no, no, no, no, you still...
Yeah, no, no, two of those kills were mine.
Two of those kills were mine.
I was almost sick.
Ah, shit, okay.
God damn.
Yeah, Axel, why do you keep stealing my kills too, man?
Come on.
Obviously, you stole Altair's kills too, right?
You want to steal from the noobs?
That's fucking crazy.
I was going to level up.
I'm not like at a fucking supermarket at 10 a.m.
All the moms after dropping off their kids at fucking primary school, they go to the supermarket, the you know dumpling pack being like hey hey hey i had my hands on that first bitch exactly exactly i then they go home and get locked in on battlefield six i don't know that feels six it's just battlefield supermarket is just like a battlefield for moms i guess hey a battlefield for moms it's a battle it's the battle royale for moms yeah you got to get the good shit and the cheap shit quick you know distribute health packs to teammates when they directly interact with you how do you guys directly interact with me oh okay guys if you press e on me you'll get health packs wait uh don't keep her you're only level two no no i'm level three i'm level three you're level two
so it's level 14.
Axel's always watching.
The hoses are watching.
What are they doing?
Why are they watching, Axel?
Are they jealous?
I don't know.
Yeah, why are they watching?
Why are they watching, guys?
Don't they know, bros before hoses?
Yeah, kind of.
You don't want to be a hope, get a bro.
That's hot.
Hose, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho oh wait i can customize my gun i forgot about that i don't remember like what's a good gun though aren't you guys excited for winter time though isn't it like christmas music and and holiday and cheer and no you know what sucks about winter it's cold i love the cold no you don't the cold is better than the hot honestly i rather i prefer the hot over the cold christmas not good you don't get red pocket you know christmas not true that's true No red pocket,
not worth it.
Unless they give you money for Christmas.
I mean, shit, if I get money for Christmas, then I'll love Christmas, man.
Shit.
I just ask for money.
The older you get the more...
What the hell?
Who you been asking for money?
Shit.
Just be like, I won't...
I'll be like, I want to buy my own presents, so just give me money.
Dang.
I will still take a Steam gift card.
oh that's true i'll take a steam gift card too oh i'm with i'm haiti's pc i believe in him he's level 30.
yeah and he likes haiti's you know that's like a bad that's like a bad you right yeah he's uh yeah he's uh oh guys guys guys oh my god i almost i cut my parachute and i thought i was gonna fall oh yeah it's fine if you fall you fall you know yeah that's just life you know
If you fall, you fall.
Yes, sir.
What can you do to stop it?
You're already falling anyway.
Exactly.
You just got accepted.
Just enjoy the free fall, just like your CSGO investments.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I remember you guys.
Yes, yes.
You remember when you guys kept trying to convince me to invest in CS?
I sold.
Everything's done.
I'm out.
I was like, guys, I don't know.
Guys, I don't think you guys should keep opening for knives, guys.
You would have made so much money.
Yeah.
I don't know, guys.
Yeah, they...
For those who don't know...
You would have made so much money, Madrilla.
You should have done it.
For those who don't know, these two try to get me to buy cases.
And I was like...
You missed out on the hype, you know?
Yeah, yeah, what hype?
It's okay, it's better.
It's better.
Oh, yeah, okay.
So what's your portfolio like now?
After your investment?
Oh, I think I made like 3 or 4K off of just knives.
I'm not even kidding.
Wait, really?
You sold early before the...
Oh, yeah, yeah, of course.
Okay, but what's...
Okay, overall profit?
Or what?
Overall profit.
Yeah, overall profit.
I don't believe you.
I think you've lost.
I think you've lost money.
I'm always good at that shit, you know?
How the heck did I open that?
Artillery strike.
Air strike.
Voss?
It's a period.
Oh, I got an artillery strike.
Oh, that's good.
That's always good.
There's an artillery strike here as well.
What's this gun?
Okay.
I don't know what gun is.
Good.
at chat what's a good gun chat's like my chat gpd good chat gpd I don't even know if I have a good gun or not oh I would like a frag grenade though oh that's not what I wanted that's my grenade where's my oh it's g okay alright wait what's six where should we go we're all the way in the corner of the map So we should probably go somewhere else.
Yeah, yeah, we should head somewhere.
But I'm gonna head over to Axel.
I'm just looting, man.
What's in my inventory?
Artillery deployed smoke.
Oh, I can deploy smoke screen.
Oh yeah, that is a pretty strong, eh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can like go, we can like cross open areas.
Oh, I haven't.
We're gonna do the missions, don't we?
I have an upgrade kit for an MK.
Whatever MG, whatever that is.
Machine gun.
Okay, I have a machine gun upgrade kit if anyone wants it.
Because I don't think I can.
I can't upgrade mine for some reason.
I don't think I can use it.
Yeah, I can't use it.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Look at that chopper over there.
Who the hell is it?
Wait, I want to fly a chopper.
A chopper?
No, choppers are.
Yeah.
But, wait, where's our Gatel?
Hades is still looting.
Come on, Hades.
Come with us, guys.
Hades, nice.
Watch this, guys.
Watch this.
Area marked.
There's people in it.
In front of me.
Okay, okay.
Oh, no, no, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I have something that's coming in very soon.
Oh, my God, reloading.
I'm reloading.
Okay, it's fine.
Don't worry.
I have...
I deployed the smoke.
This is why I needed it.
I killed one.
Okay, on my way.
Nice, nice, nice.
I have someone on me.
Can we have someone on me?
I killed another, killed another, killed another.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, I think we pulled down, pulled down.
I didn't even see anyone.
It's fine.
Oh my god, that smoke actually worked.
Oh, I just, I got shot at it.
Used it for myself.
That's crazy.
Oh, I got an intel case.
I got XP for us.
Nice.
I did that.
I used the smoke from a joke and it actually worked out for me.
Oh, hey.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, it's just a sniper rifle.
Oh, there's an airstrike.
Does anyone want the airstrike?
I got an airstrike.
I'll take it then.
What did we just do four airstrikes on that?
Oh my gosh, imagine.
You know what?
Let's do it.
Boom!
I'm receiving you four booms today.
Yeah, boom!
Boom!
Still getting kills like... Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, where is...
Oh, I see him, I see him.
Nice.
Nice shot.
Don't worry.
I put an airstrike right there.
Wait, no, no, I'm running up.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, he's dead.
Yeah, no, it's shit.
He's dead.
We killed him.
But how did you get up there?
There's a ladder.
Wait.
Air strike next to us.
Oh, there is an air strike next to us.
What if you just send a couple more?
Yeah.
Alright, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
Don't be pussy.
I'm looking through the thermal thingy.
I'm seeing people.
Yeah, where are these people?
I'm sending it in.
I don't see anyone out there.
Where is this guy's team, too?
Because it wasn't a full down.
Oh, what is going on?
Holy shit.
Guys, I don't know they're still there anymore.
You see anybody under your thermal?
Left side.
Oh yeah.
I see him, I see him!
Sixty-two?
Fifty?
Yeah, shit, that's twenty something, fuck.
He's over here, he's over here.
I don't see him anymore.
Oh, I see him, I see him!
Forty-two?
Feels dangerous!
Seventeen?
He has a teammate, he's the teammate's here or left.
He has a teammate over there.
one just one just uh parachuted yeah yeah yeah i destroyed their drone they were sending you in a bomber they just gotta get out your recon which recon is that there's there's down there they're down there as well i think they just drove away there's a couple of people surrounding us right now oh i don't like that that's not cool that's not cool
Copyright, copyright.
How the hell is that gun not breaking?
Brian, do we move?
Do we leave?
Oh, whoa, whoa, I'm getting here.
He's right here.
Right side back of that building.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
North 30.
Also here, 17, 35.
Fresh, a shot.
They're all like on the other side.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm saying an airstrike.
Send the dokey.
Send it in.
There you go.
Go on in the chopper.
Go in.
Destroy their home.
And their bloodline and ancestry.
Oh my goodness.
What the fuck on my knees?
You got your breath flew into that glass.
That's it?
Well, that was nothing.
The airstrike fucking sucked.
That was like one shot.
Did I take this over?
you can we gotta get into zone are we not in zone oh we are not in zone yeah we ain't in zone okay so there might be a team over here so you gotta be careful they're right below us right below us okay i am right above them oh wait it's right here oh she's right beside you oh my god that was
There's a long-range weapon here.
I just looked at him!
I was wondering why you were looking at him!
Did he have armor?
No, he doesn't.
Oh yeah, it's not rifle.
I'll upgrade that.
Oh, there's a sniper rifle too.
Oh, squad white.
Nice.
Is there an extra armor?
I got a few.
How the fuck did I drop this?
Alright, drop some armor here.
What the heck is that?
They fortnight built everything.
I am...
You guys see that?
I'm armoring up.
What the hell is that?
What are you guys looking at?
I just saw you fought.
Nah, that is...
East 30.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, no more second chance ladies.
Oh, alright.
We don't need second chance.
We're gamers.
Not an ammo.
Oh, okay.
That's not good.
Never mind.
Where are you guys...
Where are they shooting?
Where are you shooting at?
East 30 up the hill.
There's a floating platform.
Oh my god, wait, they aren't?
Oh my god, wait, he hits that?
Yeah, he's kind of crazy.
I don't even know.
He's crazy with that.
I don't even know, like, my drop-off for this.
Wait, they are actually hitting.
As I'm saying, I don't even know the drop-off for this.
Holy shit, they said, they really said, let me hit.
And I was like, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna be high.
He has to be high.
There's a car below us.
Okay, we gotta go to the zone.
Guys, guys, guys, we gotta go to the zone.
leaving.
Okay, I'm heading over there.
How do I jump on here?
Oh, I'm Serpentine.
I'm moving into Zarn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm moving too.
I'm moving as well with you.
I'm right behind you.
They're still trying.
The Fortniteers are still trying to shoot at us.
It's okay.
Let them Fortnite, you know?
All right.
I see gunshots to our left.
I hear gunshots to our left.
But how far?
Oh, we are so far from zone.
Wee!
You can cut these people off at chemical storage ahead of us.
Where are you going, Axel?
Axel, where the fuck are you going?
We're going to go in a zone.
It's the blue ship, right?
We gotta go.
Yeah, I was just shooting up the guys on the left.
Oh, okay, because I was just sitting.
People on the left.
Yeah, yeah, people behind us?
Behind us?
Oh, I'm looking.
Oh, he's behind that box.
Oh, you are so close to the zone, the zone, the zone, though.
That's it.
It's okay.
I'm running.
I'm with...
Intel case.
I'm with Altair right now.
That people...
West 330, West 330.
West 330.
They're running away.
I'm going right...
Who the fuck is that an artillery drop?
Okay.
I might be the first one that gets shot at, and I also have the least HP.
So, good luck to me.
I don't know how to drop any to you.
I'm sorry.
That's okay.
It's okay.
I just got cocky and stood in front of a sniper.
I have high ground there.
though I got high ground I've got the high ground now dokey bird I don't have high ground very soon I don't have high ground anymore oh I'm so I'm so scared I don't see wait Hades is so far away absentee teammate yeah he's so far let's see okay hey welcome back oh god you're so fast you can just cut you can just cut wait i hear i hear i hear a car i hear a car in front of us yep wait how do i get through other oh it's over here let's see i do i do have a sniper i found where those people were shooting us from yeah it's like an airport tower they're still shooting people from down there are they still doing it try to figure out a is there a zoom on the sniper how do i zoom in uh zoom in and scroll up and down maybe like classic classic pub j style wait what app What and then zoom in what then scroll where I see someone.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I see holes.
I see holes Can I shoot?
Can I shoot?
20 20 20 20 nice nice nice nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Mr. Hades.
Let's go.
I got shot.
I got shot I don't know where I don't know where I don't know where I don't know where I don't know where I have to I have to deal I have to deal.
Oh, I'm fine.
It's fine.
I'll try to cover Thank you.
She's, she's, she's, she's.
I'm trying to cover, but they might push me.
We gotta get inside.
I couldn't.
I was trying to cover.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, Hades, you're wild!
You're wild!
There's a guy literally in front of us.
You're fucking crazy.
I'm covering.
I'm heading over.
Yeah.
Get inside.
Get the wall.
I'm going over.
He's fucking crazy.
Oh my god, Hades.
Hades, my man.
Yeah, I was firing those.
He's a hero.
I was sticking in those guys' ass too.
Are you still there?
Are you still behind us?
Yeah, they are.
They're still sitting right here.
Top of the hill.
They're coming there.
They're coming down.
Oh yeah, they are.
They are.
That guy crouching there?
That guy there?
Alright, nice.
Hey, strike.
We gotta run.
We're going over here.
Ooh.
Running out of AR ammo.
There's a house in there.
House in here.
Hey, I'm heading over here.
Think we're safe.
For now.
Looking for AR ammo.
ADWK, I haven't seen any ammo, unfortunately.
Oh, I should.
I just see guns.
No ammo.
Yeah.
Okay.
I hear footsteps, but I don't know if that's us.
Chat say nothing, okay.
Chat say nothing.
I don't know if that's us, though.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why is this?
21, 21, right here.
On my way.
Oh, I got shot.
This gun fucking sucks.
I found out.
I'm right behind.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
I'm like right here behind chopper.
On my way.
Behind the chopper.
I'll get to the chopper.
All right, so I got out the gun.
Oh, my bag has ammo.
I didn't know that.
Okay, guys, I'm going to put out my bag out and you guys call me.
grab ammo from this all right i know i have no armor as well now yeah i have another another oh not here i see him oh the ice now over here i don't have ammo i have ammo i have so here all right this is a pretty cool fighting spot
oh bro are you okay i got him i got him i got him i got him i got him i got him i got him i got him who the hell who the hell shot me from right here right here right here one of them but thank you i can throw another oh hang in there that's it yeah i can throw oh it cancels me it cancels me i'm sorry look at me stay with me no nice nice fine goodbye i died though oh no it's haiti i'll take down it's up to you oh no nice oh you got the squad white i believe see i told you i believe it's okay you and haiti It's you in Hades.
Oh, no.
Oh, God.
I believe.
I believe in the Hades.
Oh, dude, you guys not Hades.
It's okay.
Okay, Mr. Hades seems to know what he's doing.
Yeah, he knows that he's a hero.
He's a hero.
Oh, no.
Hades is good.
No, no, no.
Bro, he's good.
That flick was kind of nasty.
Yeah, yeah.
That flick was good.
That flick was insane.
It's the controller.
It's the controller and the special.
All right.
What are they?
It's whatever guys whatever gun I had that gun was garbage that recoil is fucking shit one down Hades is pushing it is pushing He's pushing he's heading over he's pushing Oh, okay, hey the controller and the special oh wait and you like laying down and shit too very flat Oh,
my god.
Oh shit.
Oh One more one more one more Behind me.
No.
Oh, hello.
That was close.
How did you get behind me?
That sixth place?
I thought that was like the last two teams.
I felt like the last two teams.
We were kind of fucking them though.
Yeah, that was pretty fucking good.
All right.
Woohoo.
Not bad.
Okay, we're learning.
Good job on the 12 looted chests.
We're learning them.
Yes, sir.
I'm the loot goblin.
Chat, what gun did I have?
Because that gun was fucking garbage.
i'm not picking that gun up again i had like a some gun that was only for close range and the recoil was so bad now haiti's was definitely mvp though now haiti was kind of good yeah he was good oh yeah yeah actually i was spectating his name yeah he was he lived up bro let's invite him let's yo haiti haiti come on haiti and join us come on haiti join us I don't want I'm gonna add Hades I just give you like who the hell is this
squad management bug not start bug oh what I'm gonna wait social how do I add you I can't even add him wait oh leader start add me oh my god oh my god wait wait wait wait wait cancel cancel cancel cancel i don't know how do i add how do any of us add don't want me to go back to lobby or okay yeah yeah go back what what what fucking riz did you use on hey bro i just said join us that's it come join us join us let's go hubby let's go oh my god hey he's a fan okay all right How do we get you in for any request?
Oh, wait.
You're like, Hades, my Habibi, joined the squad, you know?
I recently met.
Where is he?
Wait, that will kind of go hard.
Hades, Hades, Kabbab.
I would go to that squad if he was ever running one.
Hades, Raman.
Do we have, I don't even see Hades.
Hades, add me.
I have high assassin.
Okay, wait.
I'm Hades PC, right?
was that his name i'm haiti's pc i got yeah i'm haiti's pc yeah yeah okay i sent him a request come on get mom please get in there get in there all right all right i added him where is he i got him in he's gonna carry us all right come on cut your kick cut your kick He's 80s.
Clutch or kick?
Yeah, I got him in the party.
Clutch or kick, buddy.
Yeah.
But I gotta give him the, gotta give him, you know, a bit of energy boost.
Hey, if you win this round, you get to the knife.
Okay, clutch or kick.
I will unbox another knife.
I will unbox another.
If you win this round, I will give you the knife.
If we are not top 10, we kick.
the best I could do is you know maybe eat a kebab here yeah and we're taught if we're we place 11 you're out we're getting a new person in it's true we look for a new puppy yeah we're looking for we're scouting for a new we're gonna we're gonna put you back in the shelter and adopt a new kid a new kid no go back to the orphanage you go it just wasn't a match I think I'd be open for adoption adoption not me being adopting but me adopting someone maybe in the future how much can you make from that what do you mean adopting yeah it's called it's like you know they say like well oh you mean like welfare like the more kids you adopt the more the money the more money the government gives you no no no it's like couch whipping right so you invest into kids right that you adopt oh axel axel then they go to a good university like Harvard and let's say and then they take good care of you.
right it's an investment yeah yeah that's all children or you just start project LeBron James and you know like dingles out look around yeah just like come on come on LeBron let me adopt your child please and then he'll be like all right project LeBron let's go you adopt one you adopt you love LeBron just be like show me your tallest kid It's out here,
you're going to orphanage, like, I want your tallest child, please.
And then you go, like, from orphanage and orphanage and compare the orphan heights and be like, this will be the child.
An orphan battle royale.
See, which kid is standing in last.
When you think about it, isn't that what people do about pets and dogs and stuff like that?
Yeah, that's how you do, like, the dog shows.
Finish of the, whatever the fuck they call it.
you know so it was like that has to be illegal no just be like oh i just want to have a child who i can play basketball with and then like you know you that you like hey can you like do i shoot some poops with your potential new daddy isn't blue rock like that i thought like that that blue lock that soccer anime is about like deaf game survival but like they made it with soccer right yeah normal wait i've never watched it i think they just they just got from the I don't I never watched Lula I just heard that like I just know like it's like it's like I wish I could just exile anyone from the Academy too man my fucking Umamusame runs when they fuck me over I'm like I'm a fucking just put them in the glue factory they expel these expel these horses you know like spell the horses you should make him into some delicious oh yeah it's good it's good really good yeah I'm going here beef beef uk as well jesus oh i love uk like the robbery yeah uk with the egg yolk in the in the oh yeah that's
really good all right i have this building sucks i think i hear people above oh my god what okay yeah no you don't do that goodbye goodbye ladies and gentlemen i am going on an adventure Nice.
I lived.
I don't know how to fuck that guy lost a fight.
He said.
What is this?
Oh my god, wait, I got DeFi.
I got DeFi.
Uh-oh.
That means we're not making it to top 10, guys.
No, no, no, no, no.
I got DeFi, guys.
I got DeFi, DeFi, DeFi, DeFi, DeFi.
No, no, no, we're fine.
We'll be fine.
You'll get a squad kill with that.
Don't worry.
You got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got DeFi.
I'm running.
my dfib right now what gun do i have anyway lmg oh anti-vehicle drop the villars oh wait i want that but i hear people okay hostile i gotta get over to you guys wait it doesn't oh my god okay dfib doesn't guys i found out that
okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay wow i'm whooping you um there is like a lot of people on me guys well on my way on my way luck good luck to you i'm looting i'm a loot goblin i just i don't know i don't know but i had come on guys we're on our own you know We're our own man.
We're on our own.
I don't even know what gun I used to kill these people
Oh shit Oh, I felt bad It's okay.
It's okay.
There's like there's an entire team It's a entire team I'm at the very bottom either there's going on me.
You're so healthy.
Yo, yo, we're getting Okay.
Okay.
I'm at the bottom.
I'm at the very bottom Okay.
Three people on me?
It's okay.
Let's see.
We're so good.
We're so safe.
I don't mind being down because during this time I'm down, I can browse Twitter.
You know what I'm saying?
All I'm saying, I said if you were with us, you would not have got down.
No, no, no.
I was getting ready to res you at the deploy.
You'd be chilling with me, Doki, and Doki's bloodstained on the ground.
And I'm chilling on Twitter, you know?
You're doom scrolling.
No, no, you're looking at the cosplayers, aren't you?
Wait, Doki, come here.
Oh, wait, wait.
What's that?
Let me open this up.
Oh, yeah, you're an engineer.
Oh, I'm covering you?
I'm covering you?
You know you're back alive?
You're alive right now?
Oh, there's Insta.
One mixed kebab, please.
I'm gonna grab that.
Axel, what would your death, like, what would be your last meal?
Yeah.
A last meal?
Do I get the order as much as I want, or is it just one meal?
No, yeah, we're gonna have to like a reasonable meal reasonable meal.
Okay, shit God honestly anything would be good like A bowl of noodle sounds good Like, you know nothing too crazy Uh, you know yum cha that shit is good too.
You get a bit of everything a little bit of this Yeah, a little bit of this a little bit of that, you know, you get So you just want everything, huh?
Yeah, I do.
I want some sushi, maybe.
All right.
We're picking one meal then one last what's one there's people on me there's people on me oh if it's a one last dish ducky we gotta we gotta we gotta get back with the squad no no no they gotta get back to us what the dish is if it's made by my mom it could be any dish really on my last meal i think i'm gonna like it's like people over there handmade it's like right over there behind this stack of dirt You guys got this catch on this I believe in the believe in you.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, Axu.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, artillery.
Artillery, artillery, artillery, artillery.
We gotta go.
It's fine.
I'm okay up here.
What the fuck does he have artillery?
He just spawning in.
Hey, so Hades with us, Axu.
You're on your own, buddy.
Yeah, no, I'm just looking at him.
I'm like, hello.
May I please get a kebab?
Don't see him.
Wait, I have an anti- what is this?
I have an anti-vehicle drop.
What does this do?
It's an anti-vehicle drop.
It stops vehicles from dropping.
Oh, what?
What does that mean?
Oh my god, we gotta make so much sense.
Wait, that's a chopper!
That's Hades.
Oh, fucking chopper.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
There's a chopper.
Are you guys ready?
Yes, sir.
I'm on a gauntlet gun.
All right.
Where the hell are they?
Here we go.
Helicopter.
What does that mean?
Wait, wait, wait.
What does counter measure do?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh, we're so healthy.
Wait.
How did you die?
the stream sniper how did you die sniper it's the stream sniper no no you don't know that you don't know that it's constantly killing you guys constantly killing you guys did amazing out there i'm proud of you um this is why the chopper is bad i don't understand gamers don't look up i don't understand why do these gamers look up how did they stop stealth helicopter it's going like up when the chopper was above us that's not true maybe we're not gamers that is all that is so that is not true redeploy that's where the they attacked from i have i have second chance axel does it but i do that is true i'm just chilling bro gotta get you where are you browse twitter oh wait there you guys okay oh yeah why are you browsing who are you browsing the timeline bro timeline timeline time which cosplayer yeah give us the ads yeah bro i don't just i don't just draw for free you know we gotta buy the package if you want if you want to know the buy the package oh yeah sorry oh the tier five subs no
yeah like the gifted memberships the recommended five best top tier cosplayers join my course it's in the description It only starts at $5.
Yeah, yeah.
If you join his membership, he has the list of, like, the best cost layers to follow.
It's a course.
I have taught so many students.
One student the other month has made 30K from looking at this course.
I'm looking at that.
Yes, sir.
Make sure to join my course because it is totally legit.
Not a scam.
I'm floating in the skies, man.
Shit.
Oh, squad white.
Squad white.
Did you get him?
You get him?
I killed someone.
Oh, yeah.
You killed the one guy.
There's a lot of guns here, by the way, Axel.
Where I'm at.
Yeah, I'm trying to fly in.
Yeah, we're at the Boston Dynamics right now.
You know, like the Robo Dogs?
I don't know, man.
Oh.
What?
You okay?
I died.
What?
Yeah, nice.
It's the gas-powdered potato that fucking killed me, man.
I don't know, man.
They just really seem to know where I am every time, guys.
Man, that's fucked.
Yeah, it's kind of fucked, man.
I think it's because they heard...
Wait.
Look!
Oh, nice.
Don't tell me there's another guy.
There is another guy.
No, no.
I said don't tell me.
There's... Oh, there he is!
There he go.
Nice play, nice play.
Guys, I said don't tell me.
I need to get more.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
Wow, wait, you guys are just cleaning them up.
That's right.
All right, I'm also gonna throw this here.
See, look at that, we did it.
Got an airstrike.
I'm gonna grab that.
Nice.
Oh, I'm gonna...
Oh, there's more armor here, by the way.
There's...
Oh, shit.
Shit!
What?
Oh, wait, that's a zone.
That's a zone.
I'm going in.
Oh, Hades was mad.
You fucking started yelling.
Wait, guys, how do we get out of here, guys?
Where's the door?
What's he yelling?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, that's a big-ass fire.
No, I don't know.
I don't even know what link.
even know what language he was saying i don't know if that was english oh he was like yeah he was passionate can we take this ambulance oh every fbs game guys you're muted by the way sorry mr crimson ruse the famous crimson ruse is rated me so i just had to say oh yeah during the war well if someone called me on my cell phone so oh my god you'll pick up a cell phone while you're getting shot at in the war i kind of would honestly i'd answer cell phone for you in the war really that's kind of game that's true i mean to be fair you're like oh it's you know you're like um the last time you'll ever hear oh wait there's like a guy oh someone shot me someone shot me i don't know who someone shot me on my way on my way on my way i don't know who i'm just bro i don't know who i don't know who's shooting me they know where you are they near me They have all the almost clean guys.
There's someone near you.
I don't know where.
I'm a little scared.
Let's get over here.
Or a little bit closer.
I want to see if I can get to the...
Oh my god, I actually pressed chat.
I am probably stood still for one second.
Look at him know you're a VTuber.
Look at him quit.
Hades is going to leave us.
Bro, Hades was in my chat.
He's not going to leave us.
He's right or die.
What if he doesn't know?
if he leaves that's right big team over there on top north 30 artillery strike a assault rifle i just wanted to see if there's anything good here i'm gonna try to get to these oil wells over here try to get some shelter because you know oh there's like a team right in front of the oil rings gotcha i wish i could find someone who always owns like a like what Oil rig or whatever.
Oh, like a Saudi Prince?
Yeah, dude.
There's a guy right here.
There's a team right behind you.
Okay.
I can try and do the redeploy if you, like, cover.
Sure.
I'll watch him.
Yeah, yeah.
Cover me.
I'm gonna go straight for the redeploy.
Thank you very much.
Oh, there's a team right in front of us, too.
Oh, shit.
What happened to cover me?
What happened?
Oh, that was not cover me.
That was not cover me.
I could only cover one board of you.
Oh, no.
There was a side team.
There's three teams here.
No, there's three people here.
I don't think I got covered, guys.
I don't know.
Dang.
There's a guy on the top of the hill, by the way.
Whoa!
Jade die!
You're still the guy on the top.
Oh!
My snipe!
13.
You know what?
Not top 10 though.
Wait.
Hades.
I go I go convince us not to kick you
Yon's a kebab store why should we keep you for another game
Fight for your spot Hades Who left the lobby wait did he leave the lobby there's no way He actually no he said Bad.
No, he's bad already.
I can't believe it.
He's not trying to convince us.
He left our party.
Wait, he left?
Uh-oh.
You guys made him mad.
No, it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
I think it's because someone didn't cover us.
I was covering you.
I was watching these people very gently.
He left because someone else didn't cover us.
It wasn't me.
Axel, why didn't you cover her?
Yeah, Axel, why didn't you cover us?
I was dead.
Come on, Axel.
Yeah, but like you could have not been dead.
Nah, fuck that.
I'm gonna be dead, yo.
You could have been alive.
This lab is falling for me.
You know, all in all, Hades was pretty cool.
Yeah, he was pretty.
He was pretty pretty, all right.
He was better than Axel.
Whoa, I ain't no better than that.
I'm just I got I got five kills there.
That's all I'm saying I got five kills.
I got three How much damage did you have access?
Me?
Yeah I don't know.
Oh, you know what you could do?
You could check your your squad Nah, fuck that Before all someone's hiding something Nah, nah, nah some but time i'm scared i'm scared you don't want to they want to show it who's our who's our new fourth i'm still support oh wait we don't have a fourth player might not have a fourth we don't have guys oh guys why did you bully haiti's away out there all right i said nothing i actually forgot that he was gonna leave i forgot i can't forget next time okay yeah gotta be nicer man Hades.
You were better than okay.
You were really good.
That's good.
Good on you for apologizing.
Even though it was your fault.
I'm glad you apologized.
I'm sorry that Doki was too heavy for you to carry.
Okay.
Alright.
Someone had five kills that game and it was me.
Oh hey, you guys.
We got a new guy.
Pantera.
I believe in him.
I bet he'll be better than Hades.
makes me want to eat garlic shrimp pantera why yeah no idea man but i'm just hungry would you like how are you good at wait are you good at this game pantera
if a homie got
Axel still wouldn't do it.
He'd let that guy die.
We're open to replacements.
We're open to...
You know, we're opening auditions.
Opening auditions for the newest English wave of...
This is the Replace Axel series?
They will be my test subjects.
What will happen to a human if you put them in...
You know, like in a pressure cooker?
What?
Why a pressure cooker?
Ooh, I wonder what would happen.
I feel like someone has done it before.
Well, it depends on like...
Microwave.
No, it's like you can...
What would happen to this poor little man if I put him in a microwave?
I mean, radiation.
Microwave is a radiation.
I'll just be the next Mr. Beast.
What would happen if I put someone in a microwave?
You know, he made his own amusement park in Dubai.
Oh.
Yeah, he made Mr. Beastland.
I bet we could do that.
give me i'll be like Naruto and Sasuke mr beast he's like a counterpart there's mr beast and then there's mr beastiality whoa okay that's a very different thing so i don't i mean that's very very different it's not too different what do you do what do you do on that land can you please explain um you put people in microwaves um so so so how are you a businessman Axel so why would these people come to your land I want to go to Axel's land cuz I want to die it's the next thing it's not even like humane either you know it's not even like a humane way to decide if it's humane or not you know I think that's up to like I don't know the UN to decide what's the UN what do you mean What's the UN?
United Nations.
Oh.
Universal.
Yeah, yeah.
Universal will decide if it's Universal Studios will decide.
All right.
Anyone else land with us?
I don't think so.
All right.
We came to Broke Island.
Oh, is this Broke Island?
What makes it Broke Island?
Broke Island.
some good shit i've got some okay stuff yeah i got armor i got a whole two stacks of armor intel case i need to use more of my like like util i don't use my stuff my my grenades enough what's this vehicle supply acoustic sensor ev mine no no that does there's apparently a tank here
there's a guard there's a tank yeah thank you very much on the way thank you i don't know if we should if we should take the tank because we just got targeted and died i mean if we have a card i think it's fine there's no way there's missile people that's early in the game there's no way i'm going up this mountain
i'll have to bring out tear down a little bit yeah i got you all right i brought him down you're drowning me out no that's what you get for bullying haiti's i gotta speak my truth what truth all you do is serious is smarter than it looks wait really do i make people cry oh i want to bomb this place actually makes people cry which place yeah i'm gonna bomb their house you're a bomb y'all do it do it no boss that'll be fun too you know do it everyone is tied to like one straight west and one of them has a bomb strap to them i'm like stuck here i don't know how to get through this cut the fence can i cut the fence oh my god i can cut the fence okay all right i figured it out i did not realize she figured it out i figured it out guys no assistance whatsoever with a pencil and a pad she figured it out wait where did you say people were out there west uh southwest about pretty far i'm like looking i'm right here oh well oh no that's just whatever it's like here i don't see any whoa wait is
that missile i don't see anybody i don't see axel where's axel Oh, I'm looting.
They call me the loot gobbler.
I don't see anyone here.
Wait, Pantera is so far.
Pantera is gone, gone.
It's a pretty good skin, Pantera Onka.
Right, Axel?
Pantera what?
That's a CS skin?
It's a CS skin, I think.
Hey, which one is that one?
I actually don't know.
It's the one with the Panther on it.
Yeah, that's why it's called Pantera.
is panther links it's it's a pokey's machine have you guys seen what machine yeah lander link pokey's yeah see when you say pokey's everybody thinks you're saying poker no no no no it's the pokey's machine my my my friend's favorite machine he keeps telling me to play it but i'm like Nah,
nah, nah.
I don't really like- Can you say mayonnaise?
Mayonnaise.
Also, there's a drop right here.
Okay, on away.
Alright, let's- let's- let's start and end the war for once and all.
Ketchup or mayonnaise?
Wait, it depends.
It depends.
Is it QP mayonnaise or regular mayonnaise?
Oh yeah, you get the- you get the pick and- you get the- I get the pick- okay, if I get the pick- I get the pick- I'm a ketchup person.
Oh, what's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you?
I like my eggs with ketchup.
That's wrong.
What's wrong with you?
You don't like QP mayonnaise?
It's delicious.
Try it out.
It's just salty.
I never had QP mayonnaise.
Oh, that's why you never have QP.
You've never, you never like had a childhood.
Oh.
I mean, you don't have to go off to my heart like that.
No, no, you never.
You're like, I'm not a baby.
You never had a childhood.
You gotta learn.
Check your mission.
I saw a drop here, so there were people running around here.
Yeah, there's people upstairs.
Oh, there are across the Where over here on ping two or one sorry There's no ping.
Yeah, I'm paying anything There's ping one No, no, oh wait, wait.
It's my ping from me I got one.
I got one Okay, pet.
Nice.
You stole my kill They're not downstairs Are they?
Oh, no There's the ammo.
Oh wait there.
I need that.
I need his shit.
Oh there's a lot of people there.
Some people across northwest.
Across northwest.
Okay.
I'm gonna hog around.
It's a little bit farther.
There's lots of lutes up here.
Alright.
So what's the difference about cupping mayonnaise and regular mayonnaise?
Is it just cuter or?
It's the way they make it really.
It's just better.
It's like, yeah it's just some premium mayonnaise shit.
Yeah.
There's no way to explain it.
It's just better.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
No, no.
I still remember.
Oh shit.
There's someone above cross from us.
Here.
I saw someone.
He's between my right.
On me.
43.
I got, I got a shield up.
One second.
Um, with that.
Oh, Axelion.
I got Axelion.
Where are you getting shot from?
I don't know if you smoke really the resin the resin resin did you get him oh no that he's dead okay never mind I thought he was the res guy where the fuck is he I have no idea but I heard someone I hear so many shots yeah I'm gonna go high ground we gotta move soon do we no we're We're chilling.
Up top, up top, up top, on the roof.
On the roof.
Okay.
All right.
Pull back, pull back.
I'm on the roof.
They're in the sky.
Oh, they dropped down to the bottom floor.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Because I'm on the roof.
I'm on the roof right now.
I don't see them.
They're right up here on ping.
Oh, okay.
They're so far.
Jesus Christ.
You're so fucking...
Where are these people?
They're like right below us.
Car!
god i'm so lost wait patera oh wait he got back that's the guy we killed earlier
i'm like i'm like this i'm like this close to sending an artillery strike on this building and destroying it all i'm like i hate this building i got like modern art this building no this is boston dynamics all right you said it i'm dropping it in Nice.
I hope it destroys this building.
Nah, this building is so strong.
God damn it.
We gotta go, guys.
We gotta go.
God damn it.
Oh, yeah, we gotta go.
Boston knows how to build buildings.
I like it when companies have really cool offices that work in.
Like Twitch has a cool one.
Google.
Oh, yeah.
Someone's rising.
Oh, he's right in front.
Yeah, yeah, you got him.
I thirsted him.
Oh, he has red weapons.
There's the custom weapons.
They're very strong.
Yeah, I'm grabbing both.
You have custom weapons.
They must be really good.
LMG.
Oh, my goodness.
They just, okay, cool, cool camp.
They are just camping on the top floor.
for all tear i don't know i yeah yeah just just oh my god cool he's on me he's on me he's on me oh i i tried to hit fire i tried to hit fire it was not right no he's there's okay i have my custom fire i have my custom weapon take it thirsty little hose oh my god i fucking hit fired i should not have hit fired no i thought like hit fire will work on my gun.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
I believe.
Or maybe, you know, you can deploy us.
Oh.
Do we have a redeploy?
Oh!
I don't think they want you to leave.
all right the greatest escape of your life now he run in there I believe I believe yeah see there's the closest real place oh oh that's oh was that person in front of you yeah they're getting the weapon drop I think oh god that's not just a person that's a tank it's not just a boulder it's a rock yeah oh my god that's crazy but we turned our oh it didn't fair like we're in the tank you see our like three you're like third person that is not that's crazy i feel like we're fighting forever there holy shit man i feel like we're shooting for like 20 years this game hey it's gonna be hard yeah people are gaming today that's surprising Yeah.
Like, where are my babies at?
Come on.
Hi, baby.
Where's my fucking babies?
Cue up children.
You don't have school right now.
It's the weekend.
Cue up.
Come on, slimes.
Go ahead and queue up so we can destroy you.
Where are my weekend queers at?
You don't have school right now.
Oh, thank God we don't have school.
Oh, thank God.
I hate at school.
Thank God.
I actually like it.
school a lot you like school what was your favorite subject uh sports it's not like that's gpe even physical education yeah school that's not even school well i don't tell the subjects were same to me because i was just on my phone and laptop the whole time just watching youtube videos and you know oh so you like school because you don't participate in school yes sir I just go there to meet my friends,
you know?
It was just like a hangout for you.
Yeah, it's just a daily hangout.
I walk in with my instant noodle inside the classroom.
Everyone's staring at me like I'm a glorious king eating noodles.
They're like, shit, I want some noodles too.
And then I, you know, yeah, I just tell the teacher, hey, you want some noodles too?
Shit, this noodle kind of spicy, yo.
How many times did you bring them food to school?
Oh, I really like it.
yeah pretty much uh you know like so like school is basically your daycare yeah kind of did you learn anything did you did you my second video is the powerhouse of the cell what kind of grades did you get yeah oh uh we don't talk about that yeah i agree yes i thought you like school i like the practical part of school you know oh not the theoretical one class where you get to be practical a physical education yeah i like the food tech where you did cooking and shit that was fun yeah it's like fun we get to cook they would like they would give us ingredients and they'll be like yeah they'll be like make something with these ingredients you have you have like 50 it was literally like fucking master chef fucking shit they were doing you know what the i remember i made a size a salmon carpatio i made a salmon carpatio once that was the bomb bro how old were you when you made your salmon carpatio a 16 maybe oh okay i was gonna say like are you like were you like 10 or something like make a
salmon carpatio you 10 year olds calculus in high school and i don't even use that anymore Yeah, we got phone.
What was I doing when I was 10?
I'll tell you your jump master.
I was playing Tomodachi Collection when I was like 10 years old.
Nice.
That's a good choice.
You know that game?
The Tomodachi Collection.
You know that one?
What else was I playing?
I'll tell you your Jump Master.
I don't know where you're going though.
I was pressing a space bar like 20 times.
It wasn't the one.
I was going to chemical star.
Diamond and Pearl.
the ball diamond and pearl is the best yo you know you know it's better than diamond and pearl holy that's so many people there's a lot of people there's a lot of people there's a lot of people there's a lot of people and i'm very i am very scared i am so scared and i think i might be jumped a little bit better hey guys oh we all decided to be here that's cool wait there's trucks with stuff in the back in the back no these trucks these trucks are broke as man they got what did i get i got a chair yeah you're right it is so bad yeah no what about you doky what kind of what kind of class of stuff did you like did you even like school no no i like the after school activities that you get to do after school i see no i was not a fan what the hell is the after school Like sports,
you know, like trying to get to sports and stuff.
And sports is good.
Yeah, sports is fun.
I used to touch grass.
I don't know what happened after.
Yeah, I used to be in varsity teams for sports.
I still touch grass.
I still play ball.
I go to the game.
You're such a normie.
Yeah, I'm an actual normie.
That's crazy how normie you are.
What varsity sports is you doing?
I did soccer, volley.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
Oh my God.
I'm getting shot.
I'm gonna shot at.
I don't know where they are.
Second floor, second floor, second floor.
You can see him?
Oh, I see him.
Yeah, I see him.
This thing is hard to control.
Yeah, it is.
Not this one though.
Oh, I got.
I almost got him.
Guys, leave it to me.
I'm looting.
I'm actually holding.
but i don't know where he is jesus okay we gotta add this guy this guy's crazy we gotta add him there's another team behind us yeah there's there's uh there's a guy there's a guy to our left there's a guy to the right on top of the roof on top of the roof yeah he just jumped out of me artillery strike artillery strike guys i got you i got you i got you homie yeah thank you i'm waiting i'm waiting i think i'm be safe i i don't think i'm i don't think i'm safe i'm safe i could There's another team.
There's another team right here.
Oh my god.
There's an entire new team down there.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Oh my goodness.
There's another team.
There's a full another team guys.
We no I Oh, nice That's okay.
We have second chance in 90 seconds Coming up get him get him.
He's at all okay
It's kind of nasty bro.
Oh Whoa, I still don't know what gun that is.
CLMG.
Hello, don't worry, I'm coming back.
Don't worry, we're here.
Oh my god, there is another guy with me, though.
Duro, I'm coming.
On my body.
Darn.
There's another team on us.
backing me oh that's how many people are i killed one i killed one just one just one okay okay yeah he's half hp i think but doesn't matter though he's actually half hp because i think he has armor that's here i saw gunshots earlier nice i don't see anyone there's someone over here that's the gun i'm paying the gun but there's Oh shit!
Saw me, saw me.
I'm gonna go from the other way.
I'm coming back in.
What?
What hit me?
The airstrike.
There's an airstrike!
Oh my god.
I had my sniper out.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I had my sniper out.
Back me.
Wait, where's Ark?
Where is he?
Oh he's over there.
He's coming for you.
He's coming for us.
Mr. Ark.
I'm here please please save us oh my god Altair's fracking Altair's fucking he's fucking right now we're going I'm not gonna say that word I'm reproducing he's doing it he killed some people all right oh hey P90 I like that and troubles in here is sound is that everybody i love hacking i thought so i love p90 i don't know if it's actually good but that's my favorite gun i know p90 yeah i'm just gonna read get reload new mission oh hey oh wait we have some stuff for you thank you thank you secure it before the enemy has the chance oh hey i saw a rifle i'll grab that i'll grab that where should we go i don't know i liked our our porpoise really good this piece is actually dragging out
what did you get a baby after reproduced whoa you got oh you were the mama I'm a fertile man thank you very much whoa and preg what the fuck are we talking about I'm gonna like go go go go run with this she's just in her own land of you know and preg why does girls always love watching males get pregnant is it like you're like patriots like shit yeah they drew it all these years now it's your turn it's fucking feel pain now you know what it feels like exactly must feel paid now.
You know like how the babies come out of like the booty wall?
There's a guy.
Have you ever gotten kicked in the boss?
Hey, I'm on team women's side.
Do I hop on and I take shit every day?
Like that's, you know, I don't think that's like giving birth.
I do not think that's like giving birth.
I mean, you know, maybe like 10% people in front of us jumped over.
Whoa, I'll be on baby.
He's literally on me.
Ow.
I got a heal.
i gotta heal i gotta heal too oh we're gonna kill you okay nice oh wait wait wait oh i really killed that guy too oh what plus there's one more by the uh i have the first i thirsted him that's a whole move right there i don't know like we're oh oh airstrike airstrike oh you are yeah that's a different a different squad they're striking i was having i'm trying to cover his combat against that guy i'm my guy's droning so i have to cover him i'm safe i'm safe you better be safe look at me you say what do you remember that all right nice because i'm raising you thank you no stop calling me m preg chat you
Whoa.
Hey, guys, skip this sub if you want to be M Preg Axel.
If you want a what?
If you want to M Preg Axel.
Guys, a hell no, man.
Have you guys ever seen those like things where like it simulates like period pains?
Like those little waste things?
Oh, the boys have tried it.
Yeah.
Oh, you guys tried it?
How did it feel?
I haven't tried it.
Oh, why not?
Just just do the sack whack.
The sack whack hurts even more, doesn't it?
okay but like why hasn't wait so you and axel haven't tried it nah why not yet uh lack of opportunity i mean yeah i'll just order it on i'll give you okay for like order and i'll pay you guys order it on amazon what did i pay you guys and have you as ordered each of you i once walked into a chemist like whoa guys check it out nice oh no chemist and i was like guys the zone is coming where you can feel fucking like period pain and they They looked at me like in confusion when I went to the chemist.
What?
They don't have that shit.
I don't know.
I thought you could just buy it at the fucking chemist, man.
If you go there like- Why would you buy it at the chemist?
You mean the pharmacy?
I don't know.
Yeah, you can get like no care.
We can't fucking just order it off the pharmacy.
What the- Just sell it off the counter?
Yeah, I was saying they're close to you though there.
They might as well sell, you know, like period pain simulator too.
It was like, you know, it's close enough.
80% similarity.
They just have it.
Yeah.
out of like that's part of their inventory I have the inventory stock in the back you know oh wait there's a redeploy tower simulator too and you guys have like they didn't have it they said I had to get it on Amazon but I was like no I don't want to shit on Amazon I'm old school you know I'm old school you don't want the drones to send you um I'm going over to Rez Axel wait there's someone resing there you can hear the Ready?
Yeah, yeah, look, look.
The tower's moving.
Look, look.
Oh my god!
Right in front of you.
That's not him.
Only one person.
Two people.
Wait, no.
It's okay.
You can, you can- No, you can kill your looks.
Okay.
Nice.
That's not squad white though.
That's not squad white.
There's people behind you.
People behind you, careful.
Yeah, because they raised.
They raised.
That's why.
Oh, that's not good.
Nice.
Cool, it's cool.
You guys, I don't even know where I killed this guy.
I don't know where- Oh shit!
Oh shit!
Huh?
Wow.
I don't know where that was.
There's another redeploy tower out there.
Yeah, yeah, that's the one I was supposed to go.
Wait, where is the guy I killed?
Oh, you finished him.
He disconnected.
I'm still getting shot at.
I'm still getting shot.
Oh my god, I'm still getting shot.
I'm still getting shot at.
See, this is why he dropped out of chemistry, you know, because chemistry is too hard.
I hate chemistry.
over here whoa i mean shot from my right oh anal jesus i know that one that's like pain killers hey anal one it's like somewhere here i was getting shot at you see him where is he uh 150 south i do not know where you're shooting at he's right by right over here oh okay is he dead he's cracked cracked oh they're he's right by the wall right by the wall i see him Oh,
I'm getting shot by someone else.
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Oh, that's a full squad.
It's a full squad.
We got it.
I'm just.
Oh, wow.
Let's get over to the redeploy.
Yeah, it's got this.
I believe in you.
Wait, a chemistry was hard.
You know, biology was the easiest.
Physics was my favorite.
I like physics.
Really.
Physics is hard as well.
It was just all math.
It was just all equations you just plug in.
Man, it's easy.
Biology is the easiest.
You just have to remember like which part of the limb you want to rip off on someone and then oh did you dissect frogs with their higher the resting someone oh yeah no we dissected um a sheep's brain oh i dissected a frog really i detected a like a sheep's uh oh where did you go excellent oh did they think i was like some criminal talking about where did you go excellent what happened maybe the game was like no no you mean you were not
got down bus bus how did that happen we're trying to read uh resurrect axle and then oh my god and the next just disappeared it kicked me why yeah i was gonna say what happened to you maybe i was like too much of a medicine the game you know and yeah i got uh filtered maybe just too good i don't think i just talking about ripping off windows what's this i think i might be dead boys oh you see that yeah i don't think i'm heading there yeah this is what i mean like remember i was like oh you know when i get on the plane and i just pray like we don't have research i was talking about biology and killing shit and then they're like we're cutting it we're disconnecting him from the battlefield he's just gonna die it's just boom just get him yeah because they're like how dare you kill a sheep yeah exactly but i like lamb a lot lamb meat is behavior yeah i hear people right beside me by the way so like i hope they don't see me is good though whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa ptsd oh my god war war is
bad i'm okay oh my god
no worries it's very dangerous it is bad hey please i think we can make it to the top five i mean we got yeah we got a lot of kills okay that that art guy was insane though all right we gotta get out of the party though so we can actually i don't know how you got kicked out that's crazy i don't know what happened they were like hating on me yeah the game hates me bro they're like fuck this game like he's an australian man not kick his ass bro arc was i couldn't see i'm like a friend request to arc hey arc boy join our squad all right yeah oh where the hell did he go man yeah i'm adding him as a friend i'm out we can give you a show of my if you come join us yeah join us you get ruthlessly bullied yeah no no depending on how you do only only alteria is that bully come on no no we all know what you did to that poor man Hades.
We all saw what you did to him.
I forgot about him.
We saw what you did.
That's so messed up.
You're right.
Wait, Hades is still playing here.
Wait, he's still playing, but he just, like, left us.
He's actually still playing.
Alright, Qo.
Qo's up.
Okay.
One shawarma, please.
oh i didn't accept my friend request i'm sad what if i what if he was a big streamer i can message him add friend quick message let's play again soon i sent him a message i was like let's play again soon i'm gonna send him one too you suck yeah there's like a quick message thing i'll send him one two one shawarma please yeah we all send him a message maybe i'll accept it one v one i'm gonna trust yeah he's gonna report her for harassment no he can't we can't be wait where's okay we can't be reported for harassment if we each send him one message maybe even two messages from each of us like he can't they can't report us but i'm asking him for a shawarma that he's gonna report me for harassment there's no way we're just being really apparently men don't have the same muscles that stim that get stimulated during periods so they're kind of scams wait but then okay well the women have pain simulators of ball sack like ball sack pain simulators do they have that i don't think i think i think
that's possible should we kick jokey and try oh okay like you know how to self-defend myself if you try it's a science it's science like you attack a ball sack and then like a simulator and then you hit that and then it like imitates the damage the damage oh yeah to cancel your bloodline oh why am i like a control variant no no no no yeah yeah yeah we'll find someone else to do that for us why any volunteers we're like the scientists observe we're not the participants guys wait does this guy actually his he's born on he's 69 nice on the 69th day of april nice you can tell that you can tell he's not a zoomer because it's not six seven you know we could have done this entire collab without saying that i was what is all the american people in six seven man i have no idea where it came it's from like like a new generation thing uh it's like a rapper it's it's some It came from a rapper,
but then it came from some chat on TikTok.
And he does, like, the hand thing, like, the 6-7.
6-7.
Oh, you know what?
I found out.
Okay, so, like, Marwa Rivals recently had, like, this, the land, the finals land, where it was, like, a million dollars.
And then they were doing, like, team introduction.
And one of the teams, everyone was, like, 6-7, like, as their team intro.
And I was like, what the...
And I asked about it.
And apparently, it was, like, the...
it was like the media person who directed the intro they'd be like guys we gotta do something fun and relatable why don't you guys start doing six seven as your team intro and i was like and the relatable and then the day became the villains of the esports world yeah they're like guys we got these guys why don't we guys do something funny and relatable why don't you do the six seven pose for your team intro so you guys see the i think it was you guys check out the dark zero um the dark zero team intro for the land and you see all of them who the six seven that was because of the media person that told them they did not it was not like it was not consensual so that's what it means to be pr trained now it's not consensual six seven they not they are trained They were told they were told to do it.
Ooh, a sniper.
Ooh, what do we consume?
I have a...
The brain rot is consuming everyone.
Hey, I had probably never watched Skippity Toilet, so I think I'm...
I think I'm doing okay.
I had the Skippity Toilet backpack on Fortnite.
I paid for it.
You and I were...
We are not the same.
I'm better.
I'm... I'm hip with the kids.
Why shouldn't they give us that?
memes i missed the good old memes you know okay no no each generation has my dudes each generation has their own cringe-ass memes what was my cringe-ass meme every generation has a up meme like i i mean like there was there was e like that one that i don't know how the that one got popular if it wasn't markiplier i don't think it would have blown up
It's still not working.
Oh yeah, and then I can has cheeseburger.
And then troll-lo-lo.
You mad.
You mad?
What was the?
Mi-gusta?
Okay, Mi-gusta was pretty.
Mi-gusta.
Mi-gusta was pretty pretty.
Troll-lo-lo-lo.
Troll-lo-lo-lo-lo.
I mean, trolling, rage bait is basically new gen trolling.
Yeah, rage bait is basically a new gen trolling.
he's literally just trolling yeah rage bait is new gen trolling that's literally what it means it's just what do you think is more derogatory though rage bait or troll i think trolling is just it it doesn't age well the tournament is just not as good i think yeah i i'd actually argue the opposite i think trolling is actually doing okay no it's it's kind of like for fun but then but rage baiting you you you thrive off the suffering for the people and that's a little bit too much no i love the word gaslighting that's my favorite oh gaslighting me too it's like basically manipulation but like but it sounds nice
despite going i remember when i first debuted our management was like so don't use the word gaslighting it's not a good word wait what really and i'm like really careful at the beginning yeah and i'm like stop trying to gaslight me man it's not a bad it's like the overwatch league where they said nope they weren't allowed to use the pepe frog because they thought it was like a really offensive infantry people were like penalized if they used a pepe frog not pepe man yeah yeah and then i remember like uh some overwatch players they got like uh they have to pay fines if they start t-bagging people that was crazy that's the though yeah let's make rivalries let's make storylines i know this is happening overwatch right here i don't know they see me they don't see me by the way they're just walking in front of me i'll wait for you guys i prone hey i didn't know that chat yeah some people got people were getting fine left and right for teabagging.
There's a guy on the roof.
You see him?
Oh, yeah, you definitely saw it.
Yeah.
I'm blanking this guy.
Oh, wait.
I just realized I am not part of this fight because I don't see...
I don't know where the entrance is.
Okay, guys.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm finding the door.
I'm still trying to find the door.
I'll take this.
Alright, guys.
Got knocked.
I don't know how.
On my way, on my way.
Can I knife this?
Oh, I can knife the tarp?
Okay, guys.
I figured it out.
See you?
You got him?
Alright, I'm almost there, guys.
I just...
i lost all my god he prone coming out okay we're coming i'm coming i'm coming over too my headline missed everything
i'm here i'm here he's one hp no where is he he's using my crouching strap somewhere over there it's okay i got you thank you thank you don't worry
where is he wait how did you wait you're fine where is the guy uh he ran probably like a little bit oh wait no you got one yay stole the gun sorry all right so i took the longest flank of my life and i totally yeah i came back with milk and eggs yeah i came back as with milk So I didn't realize,
you know, the green tarp fences?
I thought, like, I couldn't melee that because, you know, there's a fucking fence on top.
There's, like, a green tarp on it, you know?
I was like, bro, there's a tarp on it.
There's no way I can knife that.
That's a very strong-ass tarp.
You just gotta believe in yourself, Doki.
I did not believe in myself.
You just gotta believe.
Oh!
Air strike, air strike, air strike!
That's fine.
I'm in a good place.
Who did do that?
Oh!
Are you okay?
Yeah.
Wait, where did that airstrike come from?
I don't see anyone.
Axel, did you airstrike out there?
Nah, nah.
If it's your allies, they'll be green, you know?
You can tell the difference between green and red.
Oh, I didn't see the color.
I don't see color.
Wow.
So you blind.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay, we're all the same.
We're VTubers.
Yeah, exactly.
We're all the same.
You blind, mute, and the death.
I cast a spell where you become blind, mute, and death.
And you lose your limbs.
No, and you lose bones.
Like, I'll...
You can keep your limbs, but I'm gonna take away the bones.
I might as well keep like fucking...
Like, how do I eat?
You don't.
Like, one of my slimes.
Oh, that's true.
I can be...
I can reincarnate into a slime, like that one anime.
card name to my biggest fan oh okay no but that's not fair so i'm going to i'm going to catch another spell where uh you have no wealth like your family has no wealth so you're starting point is yeah i don't want to go back oh no okay but like but like do i go back in time or like it is it like 2025 is it is it like a year oh oh guys guys i'm four i gotta shop by something it was but i'm jumping i'm jumping people people people nice i'm down i'm down oh my god oh my god my god my second chance is just oh wait no no we all second chance that was crazy i was not expecting like a car to run over axle and then a fucking tank showing up right after that was crazy people know that we're here careful we're here we're so freezing yeah there is someone rising it's like it's so loud Come on,
come on, come on.
They're in the entire tank, Maja.
It's the engineer.
I got him.
Nice.
Did he get the res off?
I don't know.
Yeah, he did.
Well, now we gotta kill his friends, don't we?
I see him.
I got sniped.
West, west, west, across the street.
I don't care.
I'm killing this guy.
Oh, on the house.
On the building.
God.
Whoa.
I don't see him.
I'm gonna get another angle.
Fuck did he go?
I don't know, but that's a... that's that.
I'm getting closer to the house.
What?
Okay.
What happened to my parachute?
Bro, he's so far.
I'm not getting to him.
I need oh wait you got someone where where is he there's people on that house across the street yeah yeah actually you just killed someone or was I just tripping oh yeah I killed someone somehow oh wait our guy got snipped yeah I got his ass okay I'm gonna do something really crazy but I don't think they're looking they're pretty low wait where on the house you're not like close to me okay I'm well I'm up I'm actually like next to the house now I can move up because I'm running out of snip sniper ammo oh they aren't coming oh I'm trying to figure out how to get up here I'm gonna go from behind there's no way they expect me from behind watch this I might Wow.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
They just have a sniper rifle that can hit every round, I guess.
I don't know where they are.
I'm here.
I'm safe.
I'm safe here.
Okay.
Oh, he's one.
He's one.
Can you rescue Mr. NPC?
Please, please.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Oh, he dropped down.
He dropped down.
Okay.
Oh, wait, what?
He's solo!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ooh.
Oh, you made it to us.
Right below us.
Oh, they're both.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
It is not fine.
It is so not fine.
Oh no.
What is the zip here?
Oh my god, bro.
That guy was crazy though.
He was hitting nasty eyes shots.
I'm watching him.
What the fuck is a zip on this building?
Oh my god.
Give me a zip line somewhere.
Wait, he knows his utility.
Oh, never mind.
He's dead.
It's up to you.
It's one guy left.
It's one guy.
Trust me.
Axel's serious.
It's really unfortunate.
But you're our only hope.
Oh, wait.
No, you just read.
I don't like that.
Actually, just read us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's near the edge of the zone.
I believe in you.
Oh, yeah.
No, you're not going to make it.
You're not going to make it.
There's no one right over here south of you.
You know what?
Do it.
Just give it a shot, shall we?
You know what?
I'm an Australian.
I live with the bushfire.
Exactly.
You live with the bushfire.
You're so used to it.
Yeah, this is just like it's another Saturday morning for me, you know?
Yeah.
No.
I believe.
It's another Saturday morning.
And I'm American.
I got shot a lot.
Oh.
You're so fine.
Hee.
Don't burn.
Don't worry.
It's just a little five won't turn anybody.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, it's actually.
close it's too close it's too close it's too close no you're a coward axel i ain't no power you're a coward you were literally two seconds away three seconds away from death okay axel seems runs away again with full health yep runs away like a like a little bitch you know you could have you could regen hp now work that you can reach i hope someone is waiting outside that gate right there at the edge of the zone and just shoot you in the face that's right i said it all i hope that you survive and thrive i don't you know me i'm the goat you are the goat yeah axel you're the goat and i hope Oh,
is he gonna is he gonna get it?
Watch him last second.
Yeah, watch him like they all shoot him in the face right here.
Not dead!
Right here, right there.
Oh, oh!
Where did he get shot?
Bro, I don't even know.
Where the hell are these people?
Where did you even get shot?
He got shot from where he came from.
Oh, so someone's behind him.
Bro, what?
Someone was behind him?
kind of yeah that's a goddamn rat all right they did i'm sending a friend with us to the other guy always someone will see someone oh he didn't accept my friend request with instant denial no the other guy i'm gonna add this guy x 9v0 i'm gonna send him a quick message to play another
hit him with a knee house sir another yeah I did a quick message I'll send this other guy a quick message too uh view profile social menu quick message uh let's start a group say it I bet we can get top 5 I believe in us Axel you want a game Have you won a game yet?
Me?
No.
Okay.
I believe you.
Okay, I'm playing half the time drunk, okay?
Leave me alone.
Are you drunk right now?
No, I'm sleep deprived.
I'll give you that.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I mean, that's the same thing.
Hey, leave me alone, you know?
I'm just a guy.
I'm just like one of those dads who came back from the nine to five job.
And then I just want to enjoy my game.
And I'm getting, you know, I'm fighting.
Yeah, I'm just getting no life is relentlessly bullied by your teammates.
I don't know right?
How could they do this?
Unbelievable.
All right, we have ASAP Jojo.
I believe in him.
He's level 55, so he's been playing since launch Wow, ASAP for Jojo.
Yeah, father three returns home from work just to get shit on by ASAP Jojo Why is he called ASAP Jojo?
Maybe he likes power puff girls Baby, he's a rapper.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
He has a dollar sign on his name.
That's Pete.
Pete rapper.
Axel's a rapper.
Really are?
You are?
Yo, rapper is.
Axel, they call me M&M.
Yeah, give us an M&M song.
Nobody calls your M&M.
Give us a freestyle.
No, I don't do freestyles, you know.
No, no, no, no.
Freestyles from me.
Ooh, I do.
What do you do?
I can't tell you what it feels like.
I can only tell you what it really is.
said Axel, not Altair.
Oh, rapper, but like, see?
That's like asking a millionaire, hey, show me the million dollars you got.
Millionaires don't do that.
That's why they're millionaires.
You don't have to show.
They can just, they show by their clothes and their cars.
Where's your clothes and cars?
Well, I'm a rapper.
Where's your rhymes and schemes?
Yeah, where's your rhyme?
Oh, potatoes, tomatoes, the hoes, the what let's go downtown come on jojo take us to downtown no that's fine you can take us to oh no he oh where is he taking us i i don't i don't know i don't know where is he taking us i where is this where he wants to lose these houses where did he take us i don't even know where he's oh this scares the crap out of me every time yeah don't even know where he took us he just It's just some fucking random house.
A nice safe neighborhood.
On somebody's house.
Well, I don't think they're living here anymore.
Yeah, this does not look very safe for a neighborhood.
MG kit.
Grab this.
Oh, another MG kit.
I have a little engineer thing for you.
An engineer thing?
Aw.
yeah yeah yeah i'll take it that's for you to open up for us on my way i bet your rent here is pretty cheap though helicopter close to us in a war zone me keeping the rent cheap in my neighborhood starts firing fucking round make a date make if you make your neighborhood a dangerous neighborhood the rent will always be cheap bro tip life hack you guys are horrible people I don't know.
It's a life act.
Don't you have morals?
It's affordable.
Morals in this economy?
Hell no.
We're here to control the rent, you know?
Making sure that the landlords can't raise the property value.
And the property is dangerous.
They can never raise the value.
True.
Yeah.
Just like if there's a death in the lot in the...
No, I think like...
You know, I feel like...
The state agents don't tell you if someone died in your in in the home so you might have like I don't know you might have five generations of murderers who lived there before.
Yeah, why?
Show me the house facts.
Okay, why the fuck would they tell you that someone died in the home if they're trying to sell it, you know, it's not lying.
They're they're not lying if they're omitting information.
Why is there a guy here?
I don't know.
oh what but he's hurting yeah he's just right over there because the thing is like would you ever ask like a real estate agent like how many people have died in this home like that's not a normal question asked so they don't have to like have you ever asked yeah you would you have sick bastard yeah shinri's interested in that kind of stuff he's looking for a ghost yeah so oh oh that's oh okay Okay.
Okay.
I mean, I guess we could like...
Casually outing out our tower.
Yeah.
I'm just like, all right.
That's neat, I guess.
Also, I see people where there's two teams.
There's a full team here.
We shot.
What?
Wait, I have an airdrop or an airstrike.
This guy has no armor, by the way.
I'm already at 47 on him.
Oh my god.
Oh, they...
That's a big airstrike.
Yeah, they airstrike this.
No, that's me, that's me.
I just...
Oh, oh, you airstrike does.
Okay, okay.
It's a big, it's a big explosion radius, okay.
If I, okay, I got hit by that.
I got hit by your airstrike.
Skill issue, skill issue.
Oh, oh, oh, man, I'm getting shot at now.
Across at the tree?
Is it 40, 16?
It's like, yeah.
Behind us, behind us, behind us.
Behind us?
Okay.
Yeah, up the hill, up the hill.
Oh, I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
At the cell phone tower.
Radio tower?
What is that?
Oil thing?
No, that's the radio tower, I'm pretty sure.
I'm slowly walking up this.
Wait, where are you shooting at?
I don't see anyone out there.
They're definitely there.
Reach line, reach line, reach line!
Left side, left side, left side!
Oh shit.
I need a heal.
I knocked someone though.
I'm hurt.
I'm not.
I didn't lock someone but like I.
Oh my gosh.
I don't have heals.
I'm covering you.
Oh shit.
Wait, is there someone behind you?
Is there someone behind you?
No, we just got hit.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
I'm just a little greedy.
Are you safe?
Yep.
Safe, safe, safe, safe.
They're not pushing.
We're good We need to get out of here guys It's a full squad Oh my god, you are crazy How did he not die boss?
Got one, got one, got one It's up to you, it's up to you You're 1 HP and it's up to you Thank you Visa Oh no, oh I'm bled It's okay I have second chance We all have second chance I think So apparently it's like a police officer.
If you ask, they have to disclose, but they don't have to tell you.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
They don't have to tell you.
Are you a police officer?
So they can omit information about murders in the home.
Because they're trying to sell the home.
Why the fuck would they tell you?
Like there's no reason.
It's okay.
I don't think I'll ever own a home, so we'll see.
Are you kidding me?
What is up with people?
Yeah, but maybe the apartment, the apartment you're in right now is a murder.
home you didn't know that i hope no one got murdered in my family home whoa yeah who owned it before your family freshly built home yeah but who used to live in that property before you whoa it was an empty lot whoa yeah but someone can die in the empty lot it could be a native american burial ground you don't know that that's you know that is a good point yeah because always be i don't like i don't like how you can convince me so easily what if there was a war bot in that lot empty lot what if you wanted to give me a hundred dollars
let's meet up
oh behind you guys behind you guys in between me and you in between you oh this is a sniper got it oh i hate this gun what across the street there's a person okay okay i don't have ammo oh my god oh my god oh my god okay i had like just a sniper rifle axel i believe i believe in axel i believe in axel i i bursted one of them so they can't raise the other oh boy it's no oh my god it's so fast what the he just locks on like that yeah that's yeah no he just i bet the light doesn't help you there i did not help that a sniper it really okay i'm not adding this guy 20th place guys we improved yeah we definitely i don't understand it's saturday where are my children at we're we're all asleep there's no way there's no way they're asleep on a saturday it's like it's like 9 28 p.m what the what they're weak these new these zoomers you're so weak now wait do you see that guy underneath the map yeah i also do yeah yeah okay what the hell okay no this okay no this guy is hacking this guy yeah this
guy was hacking oh what that was that mr cheater right there bro oh how how how are they not on our team i don't yeah we get like trapped and then right to play with us there's that yeah that was a hacker straight up oh wait it's gen alpha now yeah what the where am i gen alphas oh wait what the is that that's the one after zoomers you know how like everything is the one's gonna be after gen alphas i think there was already a gen like i i think there is a name after gen alpha it's gen beta i think is it gen mate is it beta imagine being a beta where the is where is winfield oh my god wait level 204 i'm accepting guys the level 204 like added us okay i'm adding him in get in here winfield get the in here It's very scary as your level 204 you get your ass in here Oh leave your game leave your game right now he's he's in the game Oh he left wait he left his game he left no way ain't no way yeah yeah I literally watched him leave his game Oh my god he's in he's in you he's in 204 bro his
guys 204 if he's not carrying us like Yeah, then we're at one carryable.
No, he's all like, he looks like a pumpkin, bro.
What the fuck?
Why are you like orange and shit?
Bro, if he can't carry us, like, we're not meant to get carried.
Shit.
He's what he is right now.
We're just like there's no saving us.
There's no hope for us.
Oh, my.
Top five.
We have to get top five.
There's we have to get top five at that point.
Maybe we should have purchased more like PUBG instead of like Warzone.
but this is more more more more more okay i want to see this to level 200 and port guy which one is bro he has a is that custom bro he has a custom skin and everything he's a pumpkin oh my god he is a pumpkin bro how much money did you spend on that and that guy looks so cool and then my character looks like you see i look like i just i look out of college and sign up for the army my character looks like johnny sins yeah i got paid tuition oh yeah no i i like i joined the army to pay for tuition that's what i look like i was almost going to the army really what happened uh if i didn't get into my dream scope my at least a decent school for college then i would have gone to the army which sector were you planning
you i was gonna go marines if i could bro what you're gonna get jacked up that was gonna be cool just imagine imagine the alternate timeline we just all two sounds like this but i could have been like hey yeah hey everyone i mean at that time i was doing like so many sports i was doing you know martial arts and everything so i was in good shape that's crazy and then and then you start playing video games my condolences yeah I became a V-Tuber.
Then you started liking anime.
I saw on YouTube these V-Tubers from Hololive Productions.
And I was like, huh, I could be a V-Tuber too.
Let's go.
All right, let's go.
I'm following Winfrey.
Winifred.
That's his name, right?
Yeah, he got an IGL for us.
Yeah, he got IGL.
Bro, Winfield, use Mike.
IGL us.
you got mike anyone got mics anyone got mics please carry
all right we're going to the linden oil works are we linden oil works i believe in him yeah i mean if this is where i can meet my oil baron actually you're getting your first win today yes sir this is this is the 3d printing place Or the cool area, remember the place you got stuck at?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where I should say, like, nuke that building.
Like, fuck that building?
Yeah!
You should have sexual relations with that building.
What?
That's what you said, right?
You wanted to act that building.
Oh, oh.
You're kind of weird though.
I did not have relations with that building.
Whoa, county.
You're kind of freaky, bro.
PS brings up the worst of me.
It's like that.
You know, like, my strange...
addiction where that guy fucked his car and like married it uh why i didn't you guys don't know what kind of stuff do you watch do you guys don't know about like my strange where where are okay my strange addiction we're like i know of it but okay so there was an episode bro that episode was famous guys not know and then like you have to like confess to his dad that he was in love with his car and his dad was not happy apparently i don't know why like don't you're listening to two people who watched breaking bad within the last couple years okay we're We're a little bit,
we're a little bit, uh, slow on the whole TV thing.
I haven't even watched Breaking Bad yet, though.
Oh, you should.
No, I just see the pressing.
What the fuck is this guy?
What?
How many people are- Oh, you're dead, never mind.
I'm gonna say how- Echo, yeah.
Ping their location for us.
It's back where Axe died.
It's somewhere over here.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Oh, shit, our other guy died already.
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, you're level 204!
No, Winfield's alive, what do you mean?
Oh.
I see him.
First floor, first floor.
Wait, first floor.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's artillery, artillery, artillery, artillery, artillery.
I am... I have to scratch my nose.
I am out of the range now.
There's a lot of...
Holy shit, why are there so many airstrikes?
Yo, I'm a flank then, bitch ass.
Shit, I only had a pistol, never mind.
I'm going back.
Wait, there's stuff over here.
There's stuff over here.
Axel.
You're getting the flank that?
What happened?
And he ran away.
One dead.
Okay, I'm coming over.
I had to get away from the artillery strike.
On my body.
Oh, I'm coming over.
Oh, no.
He thirsted you.
Hi.
wait who's that oh wait that's the i got you homies that's right we thirsted him for you thank you i always can count on my friends if you're thirsting and killing people for me yeah thanks guys don't worry we always do it for our homies yeah get a get a homie that will kill for you oh we're here in front of us oh god there's two over there i have to grab armor
He's in Yeah, I'm gonna I'm taking my second armor in They're rising to our left by the way.
Oh I can't see shit.
I can't see shit now Dude, I can't see shit.
How did fucking what is this?
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know, but they're crazy They're crazy smokey here.
Holy shit.
Yeah They're crazy.
On top of me, I'm top of me, on me, on me.
Okay, come in.
There's two on me.
I'm going to throw this.
I don't know where he is, but he's on me.
They're surrounding us, I think, southwest.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, there's two of them.
Second floor first floor, second floor first.
Yeah, he's got it.
You guys got it.
he was on the corner oh that's okay uh up top up top that's okay i still have second life i have my second life mac nachos if he downs me i have my second life watch this okay not yet but it'll be there in 25 seconds oh my god oh my god they are crazy with the aim these guys it's okay i'm coming over i'm dead oh god this is not where i want to drop okay um we are gonna head over here there's two redeplores right next to you yeah i'm heading all the way to the other side bring it around town do you think there's a save It's not safe,
it's not safe, it's not safe, it's not safe, it's not safe, it's not safe.
It's not safe.
I'm goodbye.
You can do this chicken, man.
It was absolutely not safe.
I saw a guy literally just walk over there last minute.
He could have killed him.
I didn't.
No, no, no.
I think he had a team, guys.
No, I couldn't do it.
yeah you're right oh my leggies i twisted my ankle guys your legma my ligma don't worry i'll buy those crystals they'll cure my ligma the shut night right how ligma curing crystals get yours now contact regis altair and actual syrios to get scanned yeah wait what about me guys i can also scam people too we're the scammers you're the you're the fraud i'm the distributor i'm the distributor distributor yeah yeah i'll distribute the scams so the order scam now joki will deliver it to you right away no no no no i give it to you guys and then you know how like uh when you're when you know during like uh when you're dealing like drugs and stuff you know there's like the supplier and then the you guys are in the alleyway and i'm the supplier okay see you would like you would from bed yeah exactly i've never watched that is good yudia salamanca i'll be like that that paint that guy that got his half his face blown up oh that's great gustavo yeah i'm that guy we went far you can be skylar white
no no i even i know she's a yeah no no no she's skylar white yo everyone knows she's a I can be ten to them you can be ten oh is that the Sun is that the Sun no that's all for junior oh wait wait behind us behind us right here we got a danger point I don't know oh I got a sniper fuck this guy's butt cheeks it's mine I got him my god might be butt cheeks but i still got you boy but cheeks whoa i don't know where his teammates are yeah yeah yeah oh there's some stuff here where is his teammates though right here people he's probably resting so maybe just one around us yeah i don't know where he is um Checking this out.
Is there any good shit here?
No.
Where do we go?
Oh, definitely not towards the fire.
Let's go northeast.
First the seal?
All right.
I'm following Altair.
If we die is because of him, he has a bad leadership.
Woohoo!
I'm a bad leader!
Follow me guys, we're gonna die!
Yippee!
Finally.
Oh, okay.
That's scary.
We're gonna go towards combat training, actually.
I feel like, should we loot here?
Oh, sure.
I'm getting my knife out.
I'm shaking the wall.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Wall has been successfully...
Oh, they looted this area.
This area has nothing.
Leader, you have a guild of six to lead.
Yeah, but we could always have more.
Yeah, there's nothing here, though.
Look, he's a bounty hunter.
Holy fuck.
Are you guys okay?
Wait, wait, where are you getting shot at?
I'm about to die, yo.
Where did you get shot at?
Oh, this.
I have no idea.
Helicopter.
Okay.
Wait, where are you?
Up the hill, up the hill, west, hill west, west.
West, west, west, west.
I'm looking at the hill.
This guy just crouching.
I'm still looking at the hill I don't think looking anymore Yeah, I don't see anyone up there I'm still looking there's nobody there They may have backed off Yeah, they're little pussies You don't have to call them that just got it backed off strategically I'm walking straight in a straight line I don't get punished Just know that everybody has a reason for doing everything and clearly including running away cowardly nope I just running away from responsibilities my favorite things to do I'm not used any of the grenades yet you want to try no okay check it out
wait the grenades don't you friend oh no you lost your armor what did it it was on armor wait did it actually hurt you or now no no oh wait the grenades don't you friend what's the point What's the point if the nades don't blow up your friend's legs?
Let's stop playing this game.
This game's boring.
Yeah, what's the point if you can't blow up your friend's legs?
Like, what the fuck?
That's what life is all about.
I know.
It's about killing your friends and taking away their limbs.
Exactly!
I should get your butt cheeks over here.
Hurry up.
Exactly.
Wait, there's an awful lot of people that blew up.
Um, it's gonna be a while.
There's still 16 more.
Should we stay in like the hills?
Oh, no.
I'm gonna...
Fucking, we gotta find better loot, that's for sure.
Oh, I think someone just, uh, parachuted behind us south.
Wait, really?
Yeah, Winfred is- I saw a parachute cut off.
There he is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's peeing someone over there.
Careful, Axel!
They're shooting at us!
I don't know which one was my long scope, but...
Look at how they're hitting everything, hey.
Hey!
That's fucking wild.
kind of crazy pretty weird you're kind of stuck over there for a while why is this game so hot you make it hard so you want the wind more what Axel gets next that's crazy it's okay thank you it's okay I'm proning I'm crony let's get over let's let's all go somewhere yeah i don't think i like being in the open here should we get the top maybe maybe i'm using my knife to run faster because i'm carrying less equipment yeah yeah fine i'll come of course the level 200 has armor let's hug this side of the of the mountain maybe we can oh play the hill oh what what Whoa,
whoa, whoa, bro, chill.
I'm serpentine, I'm serpentine.
There's a small divot right here, small divot.
Oh, there we go.
Can't shoot me when I'm in a hole.
All right, now I can chill.
Yeah, I can chill right now.
Whoa.
We are not in the zone.
We're relaxed.
Oh, okay, never mind.
I guess we don't chill.
I didn't want to chill anyway.
I didn't want to chill.
I'm going to keep bordering the outside right over here on the west side.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Because there shouldn't be anybody from out here.
I believe.
Yep, looks pretty safe.
Yeah, I don't see anyone on the outside.
Time number five.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
Are you cool?
Are you all cool?
I sure hope they are.
Have you guys heard of YouTubers?
You guys already went down.
Oh, I got sniped.
I got sniped.
Oh, that's not cool.
Same people south.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna go into this right now.
Let's find a place and hold up.
I'm going to win.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you got shot.
You got shot by him.
The bazooka went past me and then it killed the shot him.
That was crazy.
I saw it on my own eyes.
Oh my god, I got stuck!
Oh!
The tank!
Just blew up the house!
Okay, he knows- they don't know.
The tank will know I'm in here.
There's people- there's people in that house right over here as well.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Yeah, yeah!
Guys, I think the tank will be out here!
You got this!
I think the tank will be here!
Guys!
It's okay, I'm here too.
No, it's okay.
No, you, oh, how about him?
He feels dead too.
Altair?
Oh, I'm getting shot.
I'm getting shot.
Whoa.
It's scary outside.
What the fuck was I watching?
Bro, Altair, they're all going to fucking come for us now.
I'm thinking.
I think it's a glitch to shield.
I can't pick it up.
Oh, no.
Oh.
It's okay.
I think we're very, very safe.
You and I.
We're like slimes right now.
We're just like slugs.
Don't worry.
I have.
What is this?
What's my four?
I have something on my four, but I don't know what it is.
Guys, what's my four?
What is that?
What is four?
It's your ability.
what's my ability I don't know future I don't fucking know you think I know shit I was just I just lost consciousness there for like 10 seconds oh shit okay oh yeah I might have to call this as the last one maybe shit my consciousness is flying right don't worry don't worry we will get you we will get you
He left me for one second.
What the fuck?
He killed them.
I thought that was, I thought that was up there.
Is it here?
All right, Axel, how about...
Unlucky.
Oh my god, we are so close.
Axel, how about...
One more.
You got this.
We got six points.
We're almost there.
we're almost at the next one the next one is top five out one more okay one more one more yeah no more i'm losing my we got him we got him we got him and then after that game we'll be like come on axel one more we were so close i'm gonna disappear i'm gonna go buy milk no no no no axel come back one no axel play one more come on come on last one for real for real for real last one for we're gonna get your first win right now i'm locking in for real this time no i'm gonna lock in for real no conversations about killing people no conversation about we're locked in we're so locked in we're gonna try for you we weren't trying before but this time we will yeah i'll use my left hand yeah yeah yeah i had to monitor off this entire time i was using my i was playing my character and using my ears to play i'm not sleeping this entire time you you guys shall now know the fear of oh my god locked in lock in axel i believe lock in we're locking in lock in you don't want to make you lock in axel do
you drink like two cups of caffeine
before you chug in those five hours yeah two cups of caffeine and a five hour energy drink That's seven hours of energy, right, thank you.
Yeah, and it's seven hours!
Coffee for hours!
I gotta do caffeine, sir.
Yeah, oh, and then if you get like, you know, if you get too, like, caffeinated, just calm it down with alcohol.
It's like counteracts.
By the way, that's a joke, guys.
Don't do that.
Guys, for legal reasons, that is a joke.
Do not mix alcohol and caffeine together.
I mean, some do, but, like, don't do it.
Isn't it gonna be, like, hyper...
It's gonna kill you.
Well, it's sort of like...
I mean, there's Red Bull and vodka.
Yeah, that's what they do.
Like, there's also, like, Bailey's, you know, like, uh, coffee and, uh, liquor.
I actually didn't order a Bailey's because I thought it was a regular drink.
Um, and, and I had to, I was in New York City, so I had to, like, walk back to my hotel at 9 p.m.
Not sober at all.
They named it after Bailey.
He died drinking too much.
I thought it was, like, regular coffee because they're like, oh, I was like, they're, because like it was my first time in a nice fancy restaurant and at their like i was just like oh this drink looks very expensive i'm gonna order this and they didn't id check me too so i didn't realize that what it was yeah so i i was just like i didn't realize this alcoholic i'll be at a fun time in new york city i love that place yeah it was fun and i drank the and i drank i realized it was alcohol and i was like bro it was like so expensive so i was like Might as well drink the entire thing.
Like, I was like, it was like $40 plus dollars.
I might as well.
$40 drink.
Yeah, it was a $40 drink.
So it's like, holy shit, that's a fancy-ass drink.
I don't know why I didn't fucking think it was alcohol.
Let's go somewhere a little different.
Let's go here.
Who's the fourth in their squad?
I don't know.
He was level 200, and we adopted him.
Well, you don't know Winfield V-Tuber?
Oh, shit, you're right.
No, Winfield.
field the pro gamer this guy has it's basically he's part of vsm yeah you know like the the i can solo her guy that's basically him oh shit it's not him but he's like he's like that guy before for battlefield i got one guy with my t fog t fog i have my pistol
then winfields then good job bro see axel this is what a real veteran would do yeah you would know we almost murder people yeah but in the name of the law it's not murder when you're doing it for their country it's not murder if you're doing it for content that's true that too you're protecting everyone guys there's a lot of people here and i only have my what the fuck No audio,
cool.
Battlefield, Apex Legends 2.
Oh, no.
Guys, I still have my pistol.
Stick game, guys.
Winfield's dead.
Axel's dead.
I need a second.
Um.
I still have my pistol against someone.
So, all my guns.
There's just no audio whatsoever.
My teammates may or may not have stolen my guns.
Stolen.
It's a battle, yeah.
Ghost is steam store page rated one star no audio Okay, it's fine.
Hey, Axel, do you know what this means?
Huh?
No.
One more.
Hell no.
It's okay, it's okay.
I still live.
It's okay.
I'm still alive.
I'm not no longer alive.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
I believe you, Doki, what happened?
Why would you do that?
Wait, V, why would you not have a gun?
Fucking hell.
Oh.
This is so cringe.
It's okay.
I am alive.
This is so cringe.
Oh wait.
Altair is also alive.
Okay.
You gotta go find a res.
I'll find a res for us.
Okay.
First one to find a res.
That's, uh...
Well, you're the only one alive.
Windfield?
No.
Windfield died in front of me.
Windfield died?
He, um, he made a little oopsie by the way.
landing on a person that had a gun oh so you made a little bit of an oopsie daisy you're back i'm going you're going to the redeploy right hi all right you go to that reapply i go to the next redeploy just in case i'm on a bridge
one of us is gonna get this read upload actually no i'm gonna lose oh my god oh my god oh my god there's people there's people there's people there's people okay okay okay okay okay okay okay thank god oh my god okay okay oh my god oh okay we're fine there is like an entire squad behind me i'll just tell you that it's a helicopter oh and there's no i don't think they saw me i don't think they saw me guys i'm trying to find any form of loot and it's not really been successful i want to go fishing oh we all want something in life can i loot this car does anyone oh nice there's i found so I did it.
Okay, so guys, orange fans have cars.
Weapons over here.
Wait, I can get us a car.
I'm picking you guys up with a car.
A vehicle?
Yeah, don't worry.
I have a license.
No.
I haven't driven a car in like a very long time.
I don't trust that.
Wait, I'm concerned about that.
I do have a license, but...
I can just take the...
not doing the car in a while so uh whoa whoa there you go i guess yeah so i accidentally damaged the car yeah now i can just chill in the car yeah you can chill in the car don't pass up bro button up while i join the car all right wait can this car go through the water it looks like a Humvee right it should be fine yeah it should be fine
I think he goes through the water.
Yeah, see?
Look at that.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Alright, I gotta make sure.
Vehicle supply station.
Whoa!
Oh my god, someone's gotta fix these potholes.
I think that's the least of their concerns at the moment.
No, get some loot, guys.
Go grab some guns.
Oh, that's loot.
some guns oh wait there is loot here thanks for dropping us off at soccer practice no problem guys don't worry i do it for you guys mom windfield's bullying me the man up hit him back like bro let's hit him back give him a lesson i won't i won't i won't look if you want to hit him
i'm worried about you as a parent survival of the fittest bro gunshots northeast it's make him play russian roulette you know and then you get the whole neighborhood you get a parent hey this guy one you're gonna play your russian pro that do we fight that yeah i ain't no all i'm seeing is like in the wild in the wild it's all about this right the sibling that's the most fittest survive and if they don't the mom eats the child you know like pigs okay you know how they like cage up pigs because the mommy pig can like will squish their children by rolling them over so my parents so like don't fuck with me you should be like those those twins that just like absorb their sibling in the womb oh no i did Are you dead?
Where the fuck are people?
I thought you said, okay, you said there were people here.
I trusted your intel.
I said nothing.
Axel's gonna pass out because I trusted your intel.
You know what?
Pass out, Axel.
Pass out.
All right, good night.
No, no, no, no, no.
Axel, you're gonna be here to watch us win.
Yeah, pass out after this.
I believe.
Oh, I left my car.
Oh no, what a shame.
That's our car.
Oh, that's another...
I actually died.
Holy shit.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Axel.
There's still 21 more teams left.
Don't worry.
You're five.
It's just 21 more teams.
You're still stuck with us.
Oh, 69.
Nice.
There's 69 players left.
Oh, people are dying so slow.
Oh, never mind.
67.
Haha, it's like 7.
Curse you, Doki Bird!
I'm trying to... I'm testing guns out.
Okay, we'll grab this.
Oops.
The tool.
Wow, two are you sure.
I'm just testing the gun out.
Oh, I know what gun I have.
I need to do some scouting.
Top 20!
Yay!
I thought it started with 20.
No.
It's like 20.
one.
Wait.
Let's see.
You're so far ahead.
You're just getting.
Oh, okay.
We got this.
Still at 67, guys.
They know what they want.
They want to cringe and die.
Whoa!
Wait, what?
Where are you gonna try to?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
You know, up there, you didn't tell me where you got shot at.
Well, that's the point of the scout.
I got shot first.
I was next.
Oh, no!
No!
I have something to do in 40 minutes.
No, you do.
No, you gotta play.
You gotta play another one with the- Yeah, and then Axel.
Axel.
No, you too, we enjoyed the game.
Axel, come on.
Axel, probably gonna end with if you leave though.
You can stay here for 40 minutes anyway, you know?
No, no, no, no.
Yeah, Axel, Axel.
We got in the game.
No, Axel.
Axel, we got in the game.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Axel, you can't leave.
We got in the game, though.
Axel, you can't leave me here alone with Doki.
She's gonna- Wait, what?
no wait wait that's fake news that's like you you fell down those stairs yourself buddy you axel we can't we can't end on a loss bro oh yeah we've only been bro excellent no no no no we got six place that's pretty good look look axel axel axel one more last one for real for real i yeah see win first that we can win win first go lock in Look,
look, Winfield's dead where you can.
He's gonna lock in now.
He's gonna lock in.
Axel, if you play one more, I'll open a case in Counter-Strike.
Yeah, yeah, I'll buy a case.
Axel, I'll buy a case.
I'll buy a case.
Yeah, I'll buy a case and then I'll buy you a case too, Axel.
I'll buy you a case.
Just gonna buy you a case for free real estate.
Bro, it's free real estate.
You can get a knife.
The only time I do not lay chapter is in.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
He left the lobby.
You already left the lobby.
wait he left the lobby oh i'm too quick for you oh axel come on lebron would never have done a loss he would switch teams after that loss no axel come on you're just gonna win right now what if we win right now without you axel then you would regret it all happiness no no i won't it's just the game guys you could have got your first win look we got level 60 we got a level 60 axel no no i'm dying you gotta at least watch us play this game axel just just be with us for this one game just be with us no no come on be with us watch this one game just be with yeah yeah axel just be with us in spirit you come on axel axel don't worry i'll share my screen don't worry i'll share my screen soon Yeah,
Axel.
There you go.
I got my screen share, right?
All right.
Now you're- it's like you're here.
It's like you're here, Axel.
It's like you're here with us.
I even shared my screen.
You can- Just set up for your stream while we're streaming.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, watch this.
Watch this.
You're gonna- Watch this win this.
We're gonna win this.
We're gonna win this- You guys ain't gonna win this.
You're gonna win this for you.
You know you're gonna regret this, Axel.
Axel, I hate you now.
I used to be your biggest fan.
I'm your biggest hater.
I know them.
cheaper left cheaper left wait cheaper left wait cheaper wait no ladies and gentlemen thank you very much for watching we have we have an open spot for you oh hey i believe in you i think this lobby's actually cooked that's no no no it's fine we're gonna fight yeah okay i believe in you guys is dumb yeah yeah we're gonna solo this lobby as three people we're gonna three before everyone it's time my game crashed my my my game crashed oh it's a time it's time guys look jesus is saying yo amen motherfuckers but no more these people yo i'll tell you screen share i'll tell you screen share we'll watch the spirit i'll tell you Yo,
yo, what do you mean we're gonna watch it?
You're gonna watch it.
No, no, no, no, no.
Axel, you and At, we're gonna vote gonna watch Altair.
It's okay.
We can't even get the players to this lobby though.
Oh, where's Win?
Where's Winfrey?
Where did he go?
He left too?
It's just me.
Oh.
I think I- And Chad look on him.
You know what?
Maybe this is a good place to end.
I think Axel is right.
Yeah.
I told you guys.
the god i i could hear his voice maybe i'm like ascending too high i'm flying too close to the sun it is 1 a.m apparently everyone's games crashed during that queue so i think i think that was a sign it's a sign i can hear god whispering mees right now you're gonna die soon you're gonna die soon bitch he's telling me what you're just like freedom he doesn't doesn't deserve to suffer anymore.
Yeah.
Let him go.
It is me.
Thank God.
God commands you to play one more.
I'm an atheist, so I don't believe in God.
How about this?
Maybe in return, maybe we'll have to schedule another stream at some other point.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll have another battlefield.
Oh, we gotta do some shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, guys, we should do endurance stream for battlefield until we win one game.
Oh, hey.
i do that come on come on axel and then tire endurance stream axel come on do you believe in us guys we're gonna die we're gonna die from it all right okay we get like rpr something so someone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no we can get winfried again guys yeah winfried okay i don't know you guys are telling me you guys want to die from old age let's do it next week let's do that well all i'll think about i'll think about all right axel you know you wanna stream till we win to enduring stream till we win we're gonna be here forever i think actually if we get rpr he's just gonna carry us i i actually think i think we don't even have to play the cave he's just here we shall see what happens axel look it's a free win i'll tell you i'll tell you and i i'll tell you we will message axel every day until he says yes day one thousand of messaging guys i'm uninstalling discord and then no and then we'll add him on twitter okay and then and then instagram bro i will deactivate my instagram my twitter
my discord you can't do that i'll be in your youtube chat to ask you oh well i won't stream then he's gonna go ahead thank you my gosh okay i'll tell you we can do it okay you and i we we ask axel every day until he says yes to endurance stream until we win all right some pictures of your dog i'll send pictures with my cat yeah yeah yeah and then we'll be like day one of asking axel if he if he'll play battlefield with us i'll buy counter-shut case and i'll be like hey axel this could be opened if only you play with us yeah yeah no hell no i'll buy you a case if you do it i don't need no case what do you need what do you want axel we're here to negotiate i want freedom yeah but then but then afterwards freedom doesn't taste that good yeah come on
win a game how about next week next week on on thursday how is thursday yes yeah yeah yeah next week thursday uh same time same place okay i'll see you guys on thursday you'll fucking terrible.
Yeah!
We did it!
Woo!
High five, Ducky!
Yeah!
Bye-bye!
We did it, guys!
Thank you, everybody, for joining.
Okay, okay, guys, guys, guys.
So Thursday, wait, what time are we doing?
5 p.m.
PST or 7 p.m.
PST?
Axel, can you wake up?
5 p.m.
PST on Thursday, guys.
Good night.
And then we're going to do, we enjoy until we win.
I'm going to put it on my calendar, Axel.
You can't back out.
yeah me too i'm gonna put it in my calendar i'm gonna walk out every day trying to like inhale people who are coughing like their lungs out like before say yes please
i'm gonna catch it i'm gonna catch it and go die children already but thank you thank you very much so for joining last minute thank you guys i had so much fun everyone yeah Yeah, don't worry.
We should play some more games more often.
I'm sorry.
No, it's okay.
Me too.
Don't worry, guys.
On Thursday, we're gonna win that game.
We're gonna win that game.
I believe in us.
And not- But then I'm gonna be streaming to you twice next week because I have the thing with Beto.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah.
And if not, if we don't win, at least we get to spend 12 hours together, guys.
That's the YouTube limit.
Oh.
Yeah.
I don't even get to spend.
I'm going behind myself.
on that note thank you everyone all right bye-bye run bye-bye bye guys bye-bye bye-bye all right guys so we we are a bit late for our membership stream but don't worry I need like a 15 like a we'll start at 1030 guys just need a little bit of a buffer but I had a great time I had a great time sound guy I'm sorry that Altair was so loud I hope Altair wasn't too loud everyone um because I saw that sound guy kept asking me to lower Altair so I hope he was at a decent decent sound volume at the end so yeah see yeah see we'll see it we'll see Axel and Altair again um on on Thursday and we're gonna play until until we win I believe look this was warm up today was warm up we weren't locked in and we were like We were messing up,
but of course we weren't gonna win right away.
But this time, this time, this time, next week, next week, next week, it's gonna change.
Or we're gonna have a 12-hour VOD.
It's one or the other.
I think, like, whatever happens, it'll be a good time.
Anyway, guys, I'm sorry I have to go, like, super quick because I do have a member...
I was supposed to have a member stream, like, 12 minutes ago, so...
But I do need a little bit of a buffer.
but anyway guys I hope you guys have fun time as always everybody stay hydrated pause check do you have a move around get that blood flow and you said for me head to bed cause you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys